au moment de faire la bascule de moins
en moins de gens pour cette bascule Fab
la dernière fois on était déjà que 1200
là on est plus puissant ça ne bascule
plus
après ça se comprend le tournoi est
terminé il a plus aucun intérêt
quasiment et c'est quelque part un
plaisir de voir que les gens
oui suivent et du coup en suivant pas
ouais alors que rapporte des sites de
jouer le gars Fab
l'information du jour
bon bah regardez que c'est la seule
partie qui a un intérêt donc c'est la
seule qu'on va regarder en fait enfin ce
que je te propose pour le moment
mais en réalité en fait c'est une époque
fait nul le tournoi instantanément
ternitée donc très clairement c'est la
partie à regarder
bon a priori
tu as peut-être pris le mauvais casque
femme là je vois
Fab en roue libre pour cette fin de
tournoi ouais non clairement femme en
roue libre Fab in prix
rôle quand même ouais non je disais ça
devrait être une chez sneakers du coup
ce tournoi et
bon c'est quoi le moyen le plus simple
de faire de la CAF normalement je
réfléchis avec Nico
mais en général toutes les ventes où tu
fais C4 avec les Blancs là c'est quand
même pas mal quoi
pour bloquer le jeu
allez casse Sinner avec 16h je pense
qu'on a fini d'ici là alors cette partie
peut-être mais pas forcément
pas forcément
toutes les journées
il a fait cavalier F6 qui est ici 3 mais
il peut le faire maintenant et je vois
pas depuis juste ici pourquoi pas un
petit aussi alors c'est marrant de jouer
le gars
tu peux quand même faire la
fête
attaque le pion de 5 fougères 5 et une
mais bon ça
t'enlève des vins ah une riche une
rauser la rosera
c'est marrant de jouer le gain alors que
ça sert absolument à rien c'est vrai
mais
il est bizarre en fait les pots il est
dégoûté
ouais il s'est dit pourquoi à quoi ça je
comprends en fait
c'est tellement relou
on va attendre les coups
on va avoir entendre les coups Fab
IEN
magnifique femme
donc ouais bon on va voir sûrement
fouger 5 il peut aussi jouer à
la sosie de bon c'est trop non je ferai
pas non mais il peut faire un coup comme
F3 bien sûr
c'est notre genre de ligne mais fougères
5 c'est quand même main quoi
évidemment
non c'est pas con avec une ordre sauf
que à quoi ça sert quoi
je comprends pas toujours à quoi ça sert
Fab
c'est pas très grave
de pas savoir à quoi ça sert
pour hello peut-être
oh nul c'est pas si mal
ça sert à rien mais bon peu importe
on en est plus à sa préfab non mais
nous on a plus que deux jours
on avait parlé on pensait qu'il allait
jouer à
allait faire la berlinoise autant
j'étais sûr que rapporte les jeunes
sicilienne et jouer quoi
ce qui est très bizarre parce que c'est
ouais c'est assez
mais c'est aussi peut-être pour ça que
Naka est dans le top top parce que il
est très pragmatique et il prend les
bonnes décisions et là c'est juste enfin
après si c'était que nous on jouerait
jamais on ferait que des nuls
mais non il veut jouer tout le temps
ouais mais c'est aussi bizarre parce
qu'après les interviews et tout tu vois
que ça le fait chier de jouer aux échecs
aussi il le dit plus ou moins il est
très bizarre en fait
donc on a cette position très à la mode
F4 il y en a qui font F3
quelqu'un est bizarre faut trouver ça
bizarre ça devrait plutôt vos régions de
voir une partie un peu dynamique mais en
fait c'est juste que le choix est bête
en fait
c'est un choix mais
c'est vraiment pas pragmatique en fait
je sais pas comment dire c'est
du coup c'est juste pas intéressant
c'est un choix étrange mais
après ça dépend à quel point le rapport
qui joue ce qui n'est pas en mode swing
non plus donc peut-être qu'il joue un
peu tout en disant ok au pire je propose
une un moment où je fais une répète ou
je fais un truc je laisse la porte
ouverte quelqu'un qui met qu'est-ce qui
perd à tenter oui mais qu'est-ce qui
gagne à gagner en fait il joue pour plus
rien
donc la logique veut que tu fasses une
rapide
c'est plutôt intéressant avec les Noirs
ce serait pas la même chose si rapporte
avec les Blancs il pourra aussi
et pourquoi lui on veut pas juste c'est
pas un choix bête mais on lui en veut
pas on s'en fout complètement en fait je
sais pas pourquoi je comprends pas des
fois les gens dans le chat en fait
bah
contredire ah non mais c'est un mauvais
choix c'est un mauvais choix on y peut
rien enfin c'est
juste tu peux faire nul avec les noirs
et tu décides de jouer ça pas enfin
c'est pas intéressant quoi
c'est je sais pas c'est pas pragmatique
je sais pas comment expliquer bon bah en
gros c'est la même décision que au parti
aller quoi voilà quand il avait la
répète possible quand on est pot et que
ah oui c'est ça il a répété
après il a perdu enfin je veux dire par
là c'était stupidation là on l'a dit
enfin moi je comprenais ce qu'il faisait
mais c'est vrai que c'était pas une
bonne décision pragmatique on l'a dit
c'était une mauvaise décision et il a
perdu je comprends encore ce qu'il fait
mais je pense pas que ce soit une bonne
décision non plus
en quelque part c'est un peu enfin c'est
pas lui complètement mais lui est
fioulja lui ont vraiment offert le
tournoi années en fait avec leurs deux
parties ridicules avec les Blancs il
aura un point de moins ça aurait changé
pas mal de choses en fait d'ailleurs je
pense que Naka aurait joué et
psychologiquement mentalement ça aurait
changé beaucoup de choses mais après on
y peut rien mais on va pas dire oui
magnifique il joue avec les noirs qui a
le magnifique décision ben il se trouve
que
mais normalement bon tu es content de
faire nul quoi mais bon ben écoute on va
voir on va voir qu'on est pot contre jeu
si il fait F3 F4 même un petit rabais
quel plan il va utiliser
tout le temps quand ça fait que des nuls
mais en fait ben non mais enfin c'est
pas du tout pareil c'est juste que quand
ils font nul à ranger en plein milieu
d'un tournoi c'est une chose et quand
enfin bon je sais difficile de ouais je
peux pas comprendre comment les gens
comprennent pas mais
j'ai absolument rien contre les nuls
j'aime pas quand on fait trois points à
la victoire j'ai jamais défendu ces
trucs c'est une vraie nul et que ça joue
il y a pas pénalisé les joueurs après là
disons le tournoi avec quasi fini
objectivement n'est pas gagné donc en
fait ça joue un peu pour rien et on bon
bah
tu peux enfin tu fais une petite
marionnette avec les Noirs tu sais que
pas de la jouer et puis juste un choix
logique je peux pas comprendre en fait
comment les gens peuvent c'est je sais
pas mais bon preuve s'il veut jouer avec
ça l'amuse qui joue enfin c'est pas un
problème
comme l'autre jour elle a le droit de
jouer
en refusant la répète il a le droit en
fait
c'est bizarre en fait
c'est comme enfin tu as le droit de
vouloir je citer deux quoi
en fait c'est pas un problème de faire
ça et on étudier ça et ferme ta tondeuse
et dire oui c'est très mauvais choix à
donner paumé très mauvais coups et tu
vois oui mais au moins il n'a pas nul
bon bah il y a pas nul mais enfin il se
trouve que c'est pas des bons coups je
sais pas comment
c'est juste pas un bon choix mais après
peut-être qu'il gagnera mais sur le long
terme tu dois tu dois faire berlinois
c'est nul enfin c'est tout
l'éthique n'est pas surpris mais c'est
pas une question d'éthique en fait en
plus c'est même pas d'ailleurs né pour
une casse pas mis d'accord l'autre jour
hein d'accord tu fais pas une nul on dit
quoi en fait
rapport ne veut pas fausser le toit mais
tu fausses pas enfin non mais c'est bon
vous comprenez rien c'est pas grave en
fait
de toute façon si vous comprenez pas
c'est
c'est pas un problème ouais c'est pas un
problème
il faut être
donc du coup comment tu fais nul mais là
tu peux pas faire tu dois punir et
gagner
dans un tournoi il avait besoin d'un
demi point
pour gagner le tournoi il avait un point
d'avance pour le mec est derrière il
joue plus le gain du tournoi mais bon je
vais la jouer au moins yourte taillef me
donne nul quand je veux et ok bon il se
retrouve le gaz se retrouve perdant
parce qu'il pousse trop gagnant et
l'autre propose nul
je refuse je te défonce je gagne et en
fait il a dit à Vlad en fait je l'ai pas
battu lui maintenant parce qu'en fait je
m'en fous je peux faire nul mais c'est
pour montrer à tous les autres si vous
me faites la même chose en fait je vais
juste enfin je vais je vais vous battre
et puis vous n'aurez pas de prix et puis
enfin c'est juste pour apprendre en fait
et je pense que nepo là c'est exactement
ce qu'il doit faire il doit mais c'est
ce qu'il a fait déjà compte sur audio et
c'est ce que ouais en faisant pas
et tu dois tu dois faire et dire ok bah
tu la joueras bah tu as juste perdu et
je pense que c'est la bonne attitude à
voir
et prend ceci ok c'est pas que je
connais
tu passes ton temps à dire que le chat
peut pas comprendre le mental des
joueurs au niveau mais là tu captes pas
que le mec veut gagner une partie bah
mais il a fait exactement la même chose
dans la partie aller contre
contre époux il a déjà perdu on t'a déjà
dit que c'était une mauvaise une
mauvaise décision donc il va pouvoir
gagner mais il en gagnera une un jour au
lieu de faire 5 sur 10 il va faire 2 sur
10 et ça sera pas un bon choix ça sera
pas un bon choix et rapporte il est
connu pour faire des mauvais choix tu
aurais un mvl là il aurait fait il
serait déjà dans sa chambre d'hôtel
Maxime oui en fait quasiment tous les
joueurs du tournoi a déjà box serait
dans sa chambre Nakamura la fait et
c'est fin n'importe qui aurait fait en
fait c'est juste que bah il est bizarre
et
il est fou quoi
je sais pas mais c'est très limitant
et
par avion
à la Coupe du monde mais c'est dans les
rapides quand ils ont fait leur long
match
et David gagne avec trois
après bon en général c'est plus dame un
ouf 3 les autres possibilités
mais il faut des trois pourquoi pas en
tout cas c'est pas un coup jouer en
général très très haut niveau
ok on va voir
et jouer tranquille
au moins on saura comment faire nul avec
les Blancs ce truc là
je crois
OK
et je me dis peut-être un petit H5 ici
B5 je sais pas
je sens que c'est peut-être trop tôt
[Musique]
pour le moment et tu fais baisser après
dans un gros truc
en fait c'est marrant je crois que le
truc en général c'est H6
[Musique]
à mon avis il faut juste bouffer non
il prend de me prendre à me prendre
un truc comme ça quand il va le laisser
faire le truc bien faire pour que au
moins on en parle plus quoi
mais non mais en fait c'est ça le truc
c'est que si il veut jouer dans la
continuité de jouer pour gagner il va
être obligé de prendre des risques
inconsidérés en fait
on va voir ce que je vous rapporte
un petit dessin qui peut faire autre
chose
de toute façon s'il veut jouer le gain
il va falloir qu'il abuse un peu
parce que sinon ça va tous échanger
bon de toute façon
chez Fiero contreding ça va faire nul
[Musique]
il faut qu'il rentre en gestion donc lui
c'est cool
et donc ça c'est nul sur ça c'est déjà
fait en fait
on a un cas il doit jouer
deuxième place donc lui il doit jouer
mais sans trop forcer tu dois pas faire
la tête brûlée Ding c'est bon résultat
pour lui et Raja bof Karo anal a les
deux doivent gagner en fait s'ils
veulent jouer le deuxième place
donc ça peut être la partie la plus
chaude en fait oui en fait c'est les
deux qui ont intérêt à gagner
bon après a priori deuxième place cercle
à rien enfin dans les règles du temps ça
sert à rien et je vois pas Magnus mais
bon
ou ça sert à quelque chose
ils peuvent jouer et surtout qui sont
tous les deux à un demi point derrière
donc ils sont plus ou moins obligés de
faire un et demi sur deux ok tu as envie
de recoller tout de suite
donc logique on va voir ce qui va se
passer donc celle là ça va jouer et
bon il n'a qu'à si l'obtient quelque
chose dans l'ouverture il va il va
pousser mais c'est la même truc que
l'autre jour contre firon
il a dû refaire une
je pense
sauf que il a fait faux sept c'est 4
enfin
exactement
ok car on aura déjà pas attends je suis
en train de parce qu'en fait il enfin
j'aimerais bien qu'il me voilà c'est ça
c'est exactement ce que je voulais faire
non mais c'est bien ce que fait une
époque il lui force à il le force à
prendre d'énormes risques en fait
malin
après donc ouais B5 ça tombe dans un
truc qui était joué
mais cinq très jeunes
tu penses qu'il va abuser ou tu penses
qu'il va laisser faire nul
un petit lien pour
pour le petit de la
l'initiative
[Musique]
importante j'espère que quelque chose si
vous pouvez aider à fait toi de bon
coeur quoi
en tout cas merci à tous ceux qui ont
aidé
il y a quand même 11 personnes qui ont
donné après que Mathieu on est parlé
donc c'est cool
vous pouvez donner ou jouer enfin jouer
le tournoi ce soir à partir de 20h ouais
à partir de 20
c'est le même que celui de non c'est un
c'est un une levée de fonds caritative
pour un petit carré cancer et on prend
aucun pourcentage sur sur les dons c'est
quand même important de le souligner on
y gagne rien quoi
et ça va directement aux parents du
petit pour pour qu'il puisse se soigner
et on n'a pas d'intérêt à en parler
c'est quand même important de le dire
vu que c'est pas toujours le cas de
notre côté si mais
c'est pas le cas sur tous les sur tous
les
voilà
c'est fou d'avoir préciser ça bah moi
aussi je n'étais pas au courant en fait
mais en fait je l'ai appris à deux
semaines comme vous je savais pas du
tout
du coup c'est un peu plus cher
bon ça réfléchit au théâtre on va voir
ce qu'il joue
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans la tête de
rapport ben non mais ce dont parle au
début c'est qu'en fait
j'ai tout dans la merde tout ça quoi
alors en fait en gros rapporte là je
pense il fait encore un truc où il abuse
pas il y aura nul ouais
il peut faire après je sais pas s'il
veut absolument gagner peut-être qu'il a
un contentieux avec mes pots donc on est
pas au courant mais on sait jamais après
faire des histoires entre les joueurs tu
dis ouais tiens je remonte te battre
empêcher peut-être de te qualifier ou de
faire suer enfin voilà peut-être il y a
un truc comme ça alors juste bon bah lui
il a envie
pas lui reprocher non plus c'est pas
pragmatique voilà on l'a dit maintenant
il fait sa vie et maintenant là il a pas
une exposition du tout il a encore temps
de
va essayer de se compliquer trop la vie
après si il joue B5 c'est une vraie
sicilienne bah ça joue sur B5 en général
les blancs font cavaliers
vers des 4
et ça aide de perdre des temps avec les
B4 ou quoi d'ailleurs tu stoppes un peu
l'avancée des pions noirs
donc je pense c'est l'idée de ne pas en
fait d'avoir échanger avant ces 6
c'est facile à jouer pour en épaule
bah oui enfin là il a quand même un
avantage de développement
mais oui enfin tu peux tu peux jouer le
truc c'est qu'en fait tu as comme le
montrer Fab tout à l'heure il y a plein
de ventes avec des seins que tu es
content avec les Noirs
d'égaliser et c'est très bien mais sauf
que ça échange tout et que ça fait nul
et que de buts enfin de prime abord t'as
pas à jouer ça pour faire nul donc on va
voir
après il est peut-être juste dégoûté
rapport de pas avoir fait nul dans la
première
quand il avait la pétrole et il s'était
oui bon ben fous je dois revenir à un
enfin je sais pas peut-être ça l'a rendu
fou en fait
mais je crois que c'est Caravana ou
c'est plus c'était car on est d'accord
en confère je crois que c'est de
macarona en conférence de presse en
interview d'après match qui était
dégoûté de rapport contre des pots qui a
dit bon ça fait très longtemps qu'on
sait que ça devient au noir si tu joues
et je comprends pas absolument pas le
choix de sa concurrent direct c'était
soit Naka soit carottes
c'est le mec le plus gentil du monde
quoi il est pas là à dire oui c'est un
idiot quoi mais ça se sentait en mode
enfin qu'est-ce que tu as fait en fait
évidemment ça a pas fait plaisir à ses
concurrents directs de le voir juste
donner le point sur un truc qui était
très connu donc peut-être que il veut se
racheter de ça en fait
on se dit oui bon bah je vais le battre
avec les noirs pour
pour mettre les compteurs
que ça
c'était vraiment un gros cadeau qu'il
avait fait
c'était karwana oui à ce stade c'est le
seul concurrent viable il était à 0,5
derrière ouais ouais il était bah du
coup c'était lui je me rappelle que dans
l'interview c'était
parti de 6h qu'il a fait après ça va
épuisé il a fini sur la rotule il a eu
un bah une seule période il a fait 0,5
sur 4 je crois en plein milieu mais
après c'était vraiment bien pour le
spectacle dans le tournoi qui rapporte
ça a augmenté le spectacle
de plus il a perdu mais bon c'est
regarde ce spectaculaire
tout le temps que ça joue en fait tu
peux prendre une nul ou tu peux perdre
en trois coups je joue trois coups de
plus spectaculaire
mais oui c'était ça hallucinant
à foue 3
bah oui tu peux faire fouf 4 en vrai non
mais
quand même plus tendre une position très
connue
il y a un autre ordre de coup
et c'est juste complètement mais ça
c'est complètement nul non
j'arrive fondament 3 mais
Ed se faire nul c'est bien quoi
qui est D5 Dame des cinq dames
ça tu peux signer non déjà
cette petite majorité des Noirs en fait
à la place des épaules je ferais pas en
fait je veux dire
sur des 5 je serai le dame 3 toujours
un truc assez intéressant il dit au
final les candidats se sont joués à la
ronde un avec Zine qui perd avec les
Blancs qu'on tenait pas et en fait c'est
ce qui est intéressant c'est que en
quelque sorte les candidats précédents
ce sont aussi un petit peu joué à la
rondin alors c'est guéri c'était pas
envoyé en l'air incontrôlée
en gagnant avec les noirs et c'est vrai
que ça te met devant et je sais pas ça
donne enfin ça énerve les autres en fait
ça donne aux autres envie de de battre
tiens je vais te remettre à zéro et
c'est vrai que c'est ouais ça change
beaucoup de choses ça trompe un au final
mais faudrait compter parce que j'ai
déjà parlé du ah non darognan en 2014
donc cette année il y a ça la dernière
fois il y a ça et qu'est-ce qu'ils
avaient fait karwana ou kayaki je sais
pas mais on pourra retrouver
l'historique et voir ça se trouve
ça et loin d'être anecdotique en tout
cas là ça fait deux candidats
consécutifs vous gagnez à la Ronda avec
les noirs
ça ça fait que les choses s'enchaînent
bien quoi ça fait plaisir
et puis du coup tu peux vraiment te
mettre en attente
hété en gestion très vite du coup tu te
fatigues moins les autres s'énervent et
tu ramasses tu ramasses les morts entre
guillemets après faut savoir le faire
mais ne peut
les peaux
c'est vrai aussi mais bon enfin
donc les candidats sont joués à l'achat
du billet d'avion de Ding ben ouais mais
c'est pas tout à son importance c'est
des détails mais en fait les niveaux
sont tellement serrés entre les premiers
que ça se joue au détail un peu un effet
papillon quoi
l'achat d'un billet d'avion à Pékin
provoque un époux un époux je retourne
du monde quoi
intéressant de voir si Magnus il va ou
pas pour moi enfin moi je pense
exactement comme Naka et comme Caruana
que c'est du grand cinéma quoi non la
déclaration
mais en fait ça devrait être fin pas
interdit mais en fait la feed elle
aurait dû demander à Carlson est-ce que
tu joues tu joues pas enfin avant les
candidats de clarifier
en l'air oui bien sûr ça change beaucoup
de choses mais je pense la fille aurait
dû demander à clarifier genre une
commission d'éthique demande de
clarifier genre est-ce que ce que tu as
dit est réel et si oui en fait si Fiero
déjà gagne pas bah du coup
tu vas pas choisir ton challenge enfin
oui oui non mais je veux dire tu dis tu
joues à coup sûr ou tu joues pas voilà
mais c'est vrai que ça enfin du coup
maintenant si il joue pas ça faut un peu
parce que tout le monde pense qu'il joue
quand même et ouais ce truc pour la
deuxième place ce machin ça ça change
quelques quelques trucs
mais bon moi je serai prêt à prendre les
paris et qui jouera quoi ah bah oui moi
je suis sûr qu'il joue à de toute façon
aussi mais
après je serai pas compte qu'il joue pas
s'il arrête les échecs genre par là ce
sera très bien si j'oublie champion du
monde et qui continue à jouer là ce
serait bizarre c'était ça qui l'avait
annoncé d'ailleurs mais du coup faudrait
vraiment faire une refonte du classement
fit faudrait revoir beaucoup de choses
pour pour redonner de la cohérence quoi
fait sa déclaration je crois que c'est
dans une conférence de presse ou sur
Twitter ou quoi
qui n'engage à rien mais du coup en fait
tout le monde a entendu ça a été discuté
ça a été
mais je veux dire qu'elle est
intéressante pour dire un truc
pas que tu fais pas quoi mais vous
faites quoi seulement quelques semaines
avant le match Coupe du monde car le
scénario non mais en fait il doit
évidemment garder le droit d'abandonner
au dernier moment il peut avoir des
problèmes familiaux
comme ça mais déjà en fait si tu as
l'intention de pas jouer et de quitter
le sport en fait si tu commences à
l'annoncer juste de clarifier ta
ta position genre dire non c'était du
troll et je vais jouer ou dire non c'est
vraiment l'intention d'arrêter de jouer
et vous pouvez déjà me
m'enlever du cycle quoi
vous aurez plus lui demander juste de
clarifier sa situation quelques jours
avant le début des candidats pas besoin
de le faire très longtemps à l'avance
mais ce serait étonnant après les
demi-finales de Roland-Garros par
exemple que Nadal avant fin mise à part
blessure ou quoi mais bon finalement je
joue pas la finale
c'est
d'ailleurs ce sera interdit je pense
parce que le public a acheté ses places
ou quoi tu pourrais pas refuser mon peu
importe c'est pas la question mais je
veux dire par là que je sais pas le
final de Ligue des Champions l'équipe se
qualifie puis bon ou non en fait on se
retrouve
non plus donc ça paraît normal de
clarifier quoi
c'est bien aussi pour le suspense
dans tout quoi ce que l'équipe va se
présenter avant le coup d'envoi je sais
pas c'est pas un vrai suspense
du bus
c'est beau ça a fait ça ça crée un enjeu
pour la deuxième place mais
c'est pas le but du tournoi en fait
c'est catastrophique je vais mettre en
mode
parce qu'en fait peut-être que du coup
faudrait que le deuxième déclare si je
finis deuxième peut-être que je ne
jouerai pas pour qu'il y ait de l'enjeu
dans ces conditions vraiment je suis
troisième non puis voilà enfin tous les
étages quoi si je gagne et que Carlson
accepte je ne suis pas sûr de vouloir
rejoindre enfin comme ça peut-être même
l'enjeu entre la 7e et la 8e place ça
existe
dernier vraiment je ne jouerai pas
c'est vraiment on se connait pas il
hésite au fouet 4
pour des cinq qui on prend et genre il
hésite
avec la petite lune tranquille
et sur le point de jouer
je pense qu'il va faire fouet 4
comme tu le disais mais il est pas dans
son flow habituel non normalement
il connaît mais d'où l'importance des
deux demi points donnés par
la même méthode
qu'on n'a qu'à non plus
donc c'est ça vraiment fait une énorme
différence en fait je pense qu'il aurait
été grand favori pour gagner quand même
mais ces deux demi points c'est ça te
met tellement bien tu as un tel matelas
bien
ce que je trouve que les autres points
entre guillemets il est allé les
chercher mais cela c'était vraiment deux
cadeaux net quoi près quand même aller
chercher mais c'était
pas mal de gens ont pu
dis donc à ce niveau de la compétition
tout le monde les aurait pris cela
et surtout personne ne les aurait donné
ok ça retombe dans une position plutôt
assez jouée genre quasiment 800 parties
dans la base là dessus mais oui bon
dessin que
on s'attend avoir un dessin assez vite
de peindre à part
il va faire
pour punir et pour gagner quoi
franchement même perdre a priori ça va
aller quoi
en fait c'est même pas dit que enfin à
resa va faire nul contre Ding et c'est
même pas dit que Naka il y a peu de
chance c'est toujours un monde possible
c'est pas ok dessine qu'au jouet et donc
comme on dit je m'attends à la dame 1
même si eux prend des pour liquider ça
rentre dans un truc vite égal
tu penses qu'il serait instantanément
stressé pour son match contre Carlsen
s'il joue népaud où il sera tranquille
rapidement
je sais pas si tu es si stressé la
dernière fois en fait il était tout le
temps debout quoi son sac mais
après je passe à une grande différence
ça n'empêche pas que manus reste un
meilleur joueur et voilà après dépôt va
mieux aborder il fera un meilleur match
après je sais pas à quel point comme un
an en fait il a mieux jouer dans le
deuxième que dans le premier mais ça a
pas changé oui
la mieux jouer bravo Monsieur merci au
revoir mais là c'est pareil enfin j'ai
peur que ce soit pareil mais tellement
fort Magnus mais mais il devrait faire
un meilleur match mais la mort enfin
j'espère j'espère pour lui et pour nous
aussi parce qu'un deuxième match comme
ça quoi que jusqu'à la sixième ronde
c'était facile
[Musique]
d'imploser si ça se passe mal et je
pense qu'il faut qu'il arrête avec les
régimes oui je pense qu'il doit garder
le bidon en fait le bide lui a fait
gagner deux fois les candidats et je
suis pas sûr que tu es une meilleure
résistance sans bidon
non mais qu'il fasse du sport
elle est perdu une dizaine de kilos il y
avait très très affûté mais peut-être je
vais demander des efforts
j'en sais rien en fait après je pense
qu'il faut qu'il sumo quoi il prend
encore du poids quoi je suis encore 15
kilos je t'écraser et je te pousse de
l'échiquier quoi Bing quoi tu le dégage
non mais je pense faut qu'il y aille
comme il est quoi
parce que en fait c'est quand il est
comme ça il est moins dangereux quand il
crie encore je clique d'ailleurs il
menait avec carlsey contre Carlson au
score quand il cliquait jusqu'à la
finale
après il a bien perdu cette fille là
allez cliquer
après ce qu'il a bien écouté le single
d'Amel Bacchi
viser la nul ça ne me fait pas peur
même contre la Sicilienne j'y crois
encore et encore
des
sacrifices j'en ai déjà fait si l'info
j'en ferai mais que pour un père pète
à la fin mais bon on a compris le sens
d'Amel Bacchi
on était dans le dur
quand même
ça ça réfléchit côté dépôt
une note
un peu tout le monde d'ailleurs
un rapport mais j'ai des amis qui sont
faits qui sont fait cambrioler à
Marseille mais du coup j'ai arrivé
c'était par la bande organisé j'étais
très heureux
et ça veut pas
non ils connaissent la chanson j'avais
fait découvrir
ah mais la voiture
la base
il choisit vraiment son option est-ce
que tu veux prendre pour liquider faire
nul mais bon
j'aime pas l'option
non mais le problème c'est que c'est pas
d'être drôle et donc si tu continues à
prendre autant de temps à faire des
petits choix machin tu peux vraiment
finir par perdre sans avoir joué un coup
quoi alors qu'en réalité tu dois juste
jouer et punir quoi
il va te faire [ __ ] tu fais à 3
voilà des fois bravo
peut-être qu'il va changer son
son optique dans cette partie est joué
le gain
on va voir si ça fait en fait ce serait
bien que ça fasse nul vide dans les deux
autres parties qui soit tranquille et
juste qui lui colle
donc dans sa prépa vu le les pendules il
te filent tous les pions à la dame qui
s'en fout mais
avoir des compensation quoi on va voir
les parties qui comptent ça c'est déjà
nul
ça peut faire Punto pour faire
rien n'est fait dans cette partie mais
genre on a qu'à peu faire Punto ici
ouais
mettre la pression en fait disons les
normes vont pas ok bon c'est fait
après
j'ai mal à savoir ce qui se passe
exactement
ok ils vont faire rêve 7 très bientôt
quoi pour te dégager ton cavalier donc
est-ce que tu fais F4 avant
compliqué position compliqué mais oui
trois résultats possibles
il a fait fou BK
c'est possible ça
je voulais regarder si ça ça marchait
ou pas d'ailleurs
de toute façon non par contre à 3 x 5 ed
qui est des 5 B4
je regarde tout à l'heure mais bon c'est
ok tu vas pas perdre les clés
[Musique]
ok il y a des grands actions mais
généralement super pas avec les Blancs
quand même là tu es mieux là voilà
et autre truc à dire si tu fais pas
qu'il prend F4 je crois que c'est juste
qu'il prend des cinq et c'est 4 et tu
C8 tu bouges le roi et non c'est une
pièce quoi
donc ça peut être ça ou alors fubéca 3
faut prendre ces trois dans trois c'est
paire de fou et tu as toujours l'option
des c'était un viens jour où je sais pas
tu peux vraiment faire nul en force
voilà par exemple c'est ça et donc on va
dire qu'il y a que deux fois cinq qui
qui fout le bordel mais qui va pas l'air
grandir quoi mais c'est malin en fait la
part de ne pas essayer du force à faire
comme à la première c'est fait si tu
veux t'envoyer en l'air et me donner le
point vas-y si tu veux faire nul faisons
nul bah faisons nul donc on va voir si
il rapporte
décide de la perdre ou pas
après xD C'est pas tellement nombreux
qui joue ça il y en a plein qui vous
fait des deux sur X5 il y en a plein qui
ont fait B4 aussi
une autre histoire
peut-être c'est un coup c'est juste une
bonne
c'est le coup le plus précis
on va voir ce que n'est pas connaît ou
ne connaît pas
parce qu'à mon avis il a forcément
analysé en fait ça pas spécifiquement
pour cette partie mais il doit connaître
façon à ce niveau il faut choisir
beaucoup de choses et que et que leur
n'est que leur niveau de jeu et leur
mémoire et assez impressionnante
est-ce qu'on se mettrait pas une petite
page de pub pour aider un Richie à sa
réflexion on attend 55 tête
en même temps
pour bien aider Richard
a qui enfin fait ce qu'il doit faire en
fait ce qu'il aurait dû faire déjà qu'on
ne peut donc ça c'est moi je trouve ça
très positif
d'avoir un allié resa qui enfin
prend qu'il vaut mieux gérer plutôt que
faire n'importe quoi ça fait du Bullet
toute la nuit tu peux la tête et tout
pourquoi pas
mais du coup tu fais la petite nulle
quoi
c'est peut-être enfin tu vas prendre en
maturité
donc ça c'est moi je faisais plutôt une
bonne nouvelle de le voir faire ça
personnellement Fab
peut-être qu'il a refait du Bullet toute
la nuit ou d'air je comprends pas
pourquoi il est pas allé jouer le
tournoi de Blitz hier
beaucoup de monde oui bon
ça dépend quels sont les standards bien
sûr mais
à peu près autant de monde que pour ton
match contre
connaissances il joue beaucoup de choses
très créatif enfin ok il a plein de
qualité il a plein de qualité mais j'ai
un son dans cette ouverture des fois il
a moins de
trucs mais ouais je pense qu'il est
moins préparant en profondeur que les
autres comme le a5
et donc mais même Mathieu enfin tu vois
ils Vlad qui dit qu'ils vont évidemment
connaissaient même Mathieu tu lui dis
moi aussi je connaissais en fait je
pense que tous les gens qui tout le
monde qui s'intéressent de près ou de
loin à la théorie le savent c'était
étonnant qui sache pas à lire et ça ça
veut aussi d'ailleurs
tous les gens qui sont vraiment
de fin théoriciens avaient l'air de
trouver le a5 très évident quoi
donc il peut très bien ne pas connaître
ici alors j'ai du mal à imaginer une
époque à connaître par exemple
ah bon en gros normalement X5 dans
l'optique laquelle il veut la partie
c'est logique quoi si tu vas être
cohérent
tu peux plus gagner parce que tu laisses
la paire de fou et
quel choix étrange
tu regardes la partie
et là il a laissé faire le truc
ça va très bien mais pourquoi il a
changé ou quoi je sais pas enfin c'est
une qui a changé de mémoire
est-ce que c'est une épaule avec le
temps s'arrête non non le tournoi a
continué encore demain encore demain
ouais non non quoi qu'il arrive ça joue
même quand c'est terminé ça joue encore
donc demain quoi qu'il se passe ça
jouera on est où 15 heures rendez-vous
15h lundi c'est vrai que ça peut être
contre intuitif de base
mais le tournoi ne finit pas un dimanche
enfin il va peut-être finir dimanche
entre guillemets pour le suspense mais
mais le tournoi termine dans lundi
je crois que c'est parce que les billets
d'avion retour sont moins chers
la remise le jour après départ du genre
mardi ouais mais tu as peut-être des
gens dans l'intendance qui a peut-être
que le mardi c'est quand même moins cher
que le lundi aussi tu as des gens je
sais pas
important d'économiser sur les billets
d'avion Fab et sur les hôtels aussi
c'est une belle spécificité des échecs
de quasiment jamais finir un dimanche
les open merci
les joueurs peuvent se lâcher proposer
un meilleur jeu ou ce sera plus du jeu
sans aucune motivation bah normalement
en fait ils ont aucun intérêt à jouer
des prépas sur des parties qui ont plus
dangereux donc nous clairement le niveau
de jeu va être moins bon très clairement
après ils peuvent se lâcher justement ça
fait des artistes spectaculaires ça
s'empêche pas mais dans la précision de
jeu et ce qui m'ont montré ça sera moins
intéressant ça c'est sûr ils vont
préférer garder leur préparation et ce
qui peut leur rester de secret soit pour
les tournois des recours de l'année
comme la Silic filk up ou quoi là ils
pourront en jouer des prépas parce que
le cycle de championnat du monde est
loin maintenant mais globalement il
préfère garder ça pour des parties en
jeu bien évidemment c'est tellement
difficile de trouver une idée que c'est
bête de la gaspiller
non mais ils peuvent jouer des lignes de
seconde ou troisième importance dans la
théorie
ou des trucs même s'ils sont nouveaux
que tout le monde sait genre saignement
de l'ordi ils le savent tous ouais c'est
ça ouais par contre il y aura pas de tu
vas les H4 comme Carola non
mais s'ils ont une prépa qui pense que
beaucoup de monde a déjà ils vont la
placer parce qu'ils c'est pas moi qui la
place c'est quelqu'un d'autre
et donc
elle sera de toute façon perdue elle est
déjà connue par trop de monde c'est déjà
plus de nouveautés en fait quelque part
tu vois ça m'arrive quand je parle avec
Vlad par exemple disons on avait tel
nouveauté bon on savait probablement
Guiri Carlson avait Sow probable aussi
les autres on est moins sûr donc ça là
en fait tu vas la placer quand tu penses
que tu as une nouveauté que tu es
vraiment le seul à avoir tu vas la
garder mais ils ont si tu joues contre
apporte à une nouveauté mais tu sais que
nepo Carlson guérisseau peut-être Maxime
ont déjà tu dis oui bon enfin
si tu as une nouveauté que tu penses il
y a que toi et Max un des autres mais tu
sais pas lequel ben tu vas plutôt la
garder pour une partie comme ça
parce que une votée peuvent être
trouvées par le joueur plutôt que c'est
second nom mais ça dépend des joueurs
mais genre par exemple un Guiri oui il y
a d'autres joueurs qui travaillent moins
ces choses là je pense pas vraiment la
théorie du tout et qui laisse tout le
travail à leur équipe mais à certains
ont gardé cette habitude de chercher je
pense qu'un mag du sport par exemple
mais le plus souvent ce sont évidemment
les équipes quand même mais
les joueurs peuvent aider à donner la
direction peuvent c'est un peu comme un
comme un pilote de Formule 1 c'est pas
forcément lui qui fait les réglages de
la voiture mais il dit tiens il fera un
peu plus d'animaux
et tout et après c'est les ingénieurs et
les mécanos qui tu sais que c'est très
important souvent les gens sous-estiment
l'importance du pilote dans ce travail
là quand la voiture marche mieux ou quoi
des fois c'est parce que le pilote a
fait des retours
l'analyse pas beaucoup à l'ordi Magnus
je n'en sais rien mais je pense c'est
une très bonne idée de pas le faire je
sais qu'ils vent de chou qui touchait
pas par exemple c'était clair il avait
donné une interview quoi il ne regarde
jamais ce que dit Nordine a rien à faire
il veut pas se corrompre sa manière de
penser et c'est une très bonne idée en
fait toi tu joues tes parties et tu as
les autres qui font le travail le sale
boulot en fait j'ai envie de dire
quelque part
la rigueur et te dire ça c'est job c'est
pas jouable regarde ça nanana et voilà
mais en fait à partir du moment où tu
commences à trop faire de l'ordi tu
regardes que son évaluation tu penses
plus par toi-même tu t'entraînes plus à
ça tu perds tes de ton intuition tu
perds des choses donc si Magnus le fait
pas j'ai envie de dire bonne chose pour
lui
je suis heureuse de faire une petite
pause Fab allez avec la petite pub avec
la petite pub
complètement alors attends il me faut
une petite minute pour réussir à envoyer
du coup ça part
c'est reparti c'est reparti alors on a
eu quelques couches
il a pris en C3 dame prend C3 et il a
requé donc écoute c'est pas une position
très dangereuse pour pour mes pots qui
jouent vraiment le gain alors où il joue
la nul dur à dire
j'ai quatre ça donne toujours envie
pour C8 du coup sur G4
je crois qu'il faut arrêter
non mais tu te casses avec ta dame 3
dans le 3
je sais pas moi je ne préférence pour
pour les blancs ici moi aussi mais c'est
paire de fou et je sais pas j'ai
l'impression que le rock
noir se retrouve plus vite sous tension
parce que tu vas voir le G5 qui va créer
une zone de conflit quoi
bon j'ai 4 normal après peut-être que
j'ai 4 fois aussi fin comme ça
c'est beaucoup plus dans l'esprit du
truc
en fait tu fais faut ça il faut avoir un
truc simple mais en fait j'avais pas vu
caca donc forcément alors juste pour
montrer le problème c'est Dame G5 échec
d'où l'intérêt de toujours mettre son
rabais enfin là juste il avait pas le
temps mais genre c'est ça illustre bien
pour qu'on vous dit souvent quand on
fait grand rock on aime mettre Laurent
bien ça évite les soucis il y a toujours
des problèmes
donc ouais non mais j'ai 4 c'est enfin
tout indique de jeux G4 ici
complètement
mais une époque uniquement que
d'habitude avec
une pression gagne un tournoi même si là
bon il a tellement de marge ça ça peut
faire des jouets il déjoue pas il joue
pas mal j'ai commencé un peu changer
quand même même en termes d'attitude
dans l'attitude et tout comment c'est
ouais mais là moi ce qui m'inquiète avec
cette partie c'est qu'on retrouve le
dépôt du match championnat du monde
j'ai peur qu'il refasse la ça contre
Carlson de public en fait
j'ai toujours dit
non mais là tu peux juste envoyer tu
cliques un G4 quoi
après si un café nul ouais pas parce que
tu fais
la partie
la seule l'autre partie maintenant
ok c'est ok bon
je sais pas trop comment évaluer très
bizarre la position mais
j'aurais l'impression que ça doit plus
ou moins aller pour Douda moi
il faut drap faire un F7 tôt ou tard
quoi
après il a vraiment le mérite de la
jouer on a qu'à un fond
ça on peut pas lui enlever
et de ne pas regarder contre qui joue
demain
extraordinaire que il joue un Raja
bofile le Punto aura déjà bof et que du
coup ça ça dépasse Naka et que ça le
rend absolument fou quoi
genre tous les gens qui foutent des
petits fous qui filent des puntos dans
le mauvais sens quoi
[Musique]
ça c'est nul en fait sans trop de soucis
d'ailleurs je crois
j'ai un truc comme ça rappelle la finale
extraordinaire entre
Carlson et kariakin dans le match
championnats
mais la partie était extraordinaire
il a mis le fou en B2 le machin et tout
c'était une super partie quel kiffe
cette game
globalement c'est des partages avaient
été très intéressant à suivre dans le
match Carlson caritine le niveau de jeu
développé par Carlsen il jouait aussi
bien qu'en longue en fait c'était
incroyable
oui mais il a fait deux nuls en
souffrance
en fait mais il tenait quoi
mais c'était 4 belles parties et
franchement les trois premiers rapides
c'était niveau de jeu du long ah puis
comme il finit le match
c'est une vraie belle fin quoi non c'est
quatre parties étaient extraordinaire
franchement c'est
un des meilleurs moments de stream
c'est 4 game
alors que les quatre game de carwana
contre Carlsen c'était trop facile
trop massacrant
pourquoi
la volonté de gagner avec la défaite en
souvenir un choc dans la tête bah c'est
dur hein
approche il est temps de se dire merci
je suis l'être humain le plus heureux à
chaque passage de bits devant la caméra
pour cela infiniment merci mais on en
parlait avec Fab peut-être que pour le
match championnat du monde si c'est néo
contre Carlson ce qui semble être le cas
enfin de toute façon les pots contre qui
ce soir je voulais sortir une petite
ligne de t-shirt seulement XL et double
XL avec écrit dessus tu es mal à la
taille du bide quoi
je trouve que ce serait une magnifique
idée
c'est beau de le sortir quand XL et
double XL et triple XL peut-être c'est
mal à la taille du bide ça fait
tellement plaisir en fait
déjà il y avait eu que trois parties
entre Carlson et karena en départage
mais il y avait 8 de 0 non 2 3 1 2 3
c'est
pas si grave là le jour il a perdu une
ça a été juste fini complètement quoi
donc
corriger ça
et puis jouer le mars
il y a peut-être des murs de partout
mais pas le même mur tout le temps
mental mais aussi moi j'irai dans la fin
dans l'approche des ouvertures avec les
Blancs
peut-être changer de ma sœur
il va pas avoir une faille dans
l'ouverture facile mais en gros oui il
marche à
[Musique]
un truc comme ça tu vas jamais le
convertir
c'est même pas le meilleur joueur du
monde c'est le meilleur joueur de
l'histoire je pense
donc il faut
ce qui avait été annoncé par Vlad
immédiatement d'ailleurs peut-être les
Causses non mais oui ou pas OK ou j'en
sais rien ou tu veux un peu dans
l'italienne tu tentes tes anglaises
comme une attente une fois voilà comme
burly n'est pas jouer C4 c'est ça
même faire un cavalier c'est trois à la
rigueur
faut arriver à j'en sais rien enfin
juste pas lui donner sa position
mais pendant en synchrone il était au
niveau des pots il y a rien à dire
comme ça
[Musique]
mais ouais il aime bien le faire en
rapide
qu'environ
je sais pas ce que c'est
encore au top il a des 24 quoi avec les
causes avec
en longue ouais
avec écossaise je pense je vais checker
je pense tu peux être dégommer ouais
avec l'écossaise mais
tu peux la jouer qu'une fois
par contre ouais c'est tu l'as fait une
fois tu la feras pas de quoi
et que ça sonne sur tous les nuls
rapides à haut niveau ben ce qu'ils font
la carte cavaliers mais ça c'est parce
qu'il faut la joue pour faire nul comme
à resa aujourd'hui je vous mets
très bien c'est chaud mais c'est un trou
de mémoire tu peux avoir des idées et
puis voilà
c'est quoi ce truc
ah [ __ ] il avait pas gagné en fait
il fait nulst Londres en 2017 il avait
je crois qu'il y a une pièce de plus
j'ai pas de conneries
un truc comme ça je pensais qu'il allait
gagner cette partie
en fait il est pas arrivé
donc on va il est pas gagné
une position quasi gagnante contre
Magnus avec l'écossaise ouais l'écossais
c'est vraiment service volé en fait
et dans le tennis moderne tu peux plus
faire enfin il y a plus de joueurs au
top top qui font service volet à tous
les points mais sur un point de temps en
temps au bon moment tu surprends quoi tu
surprends et ça peut faire mal
mais juste c'est pas une stratégie enfin
c'est pas c'est dans ta stratégie de
match mais c'est une stratégie pour arme
surprise j'ai jamais fait monter à la
volée sur seconde balle
qui peut être très violent
es
d'opposition qui te revient aussi vite
pas sûr que si il y a une victoire c'est
sûr
c'est sûr qu'il en a une
du coup
on sent qu'on a pas vraiment de partie
au niveau là
je comprends pas pourquoi ça peut pas
être joué sur tout le match si c'est
archi préparé c'était que ça bah parce
qu'en fait les Noirs ils vont
je peux pas en fait
maxime a battu Carlson je crois que
Maxime est venu c'est soit neuf deux
soit 11-2 je crois que c'est 9 2 en
partie non
je suis pas sûr j'ai vu ça il y a pas
longtemps et du coup je me rappelle plus
si c'était
deux ou si c'était
enfin tu m'as compris ah non mais c'est
sûr résultats
en doux et ces deux victoires Maxime et
9 Magnus ou si c'est 11 victoires Magnus
je me rappelle plus ok ouais mais il y a
une victoire quand ils étaient jeunes à
Lausanne non ça bien et une adulte à la
cyclefield
ce qui est déjà bien
elle aurait pu être à 3 ouais
toute façon c'est dur hein contre Magnus
ouais donc écoute 5 globalement les
normes choix
soit faire un goût comme Thor C8 je
pense que niveau on va pas se priver
pour tout liquider
ce genre de
7 mais en fait il faut des 6 qui est pas
mal
tu es passé devant et oui
je sais pas à quel point tu es mieux
mais tu es plutôt mieux
bon ça ressemble un truc français
[Musique]
impossible impossible deux fois il gagne
et je me demande si c'est pas un tu vois
c'était pas un clin d'œil
il a toujours su en fait
les gains pour le gain avec les Blancs
aujourd'hui bah oui non en fait non lui
nul ça lui va très bien après si jamais
à Richard des rats ou quoi il ira
prendre le point c'est tout donc s'il
prend trop de réussir avec les Noirs par
exemple ou quoi il va jouer
et il va punir
il va il va faire du dames 3 du Tour de
trucs comme ça il va partir t'attaquer
quoi
on va voir ce que ça joue côté rapporte
le temps une heure vin de chaque côté
en fait j'ai l'impression de me donner
pas beaucoup réfléchi mais c'est selon
ces standard en fait par rapport à
rapporte pas tellement
Fab
IEN ok il va faire nul
alors déjà gagnant pour Ikao enfin gros
avantage mais bon c'est hyper compliqué
il a laissé le temps avec faire H4 donc
à pouvoir installer son cavalier avec H5
qui pénible ce cavalier après je sais
pas toute leur vie s'enflamme mais là
pour le coup même visuellement ça a
l'air juste pas trop mal pour les blancs
quoi parce que en fait dans ces
structures souvent on les a expliqué on
se dit ouais les noms du jeu sur la
colonel blablabla ce qui est vrai
normalement mais si tu as pas de Tours
en fait donc avoir
sans la petite nul
[Musique]
merci beaucoup les parfaitement adapté
pour moi jamais rencontré un livre
expliquant aussi bien les finales
je crois que Baki suite de mes
excellent livre
que je le connais pas en fait
moi je recommande souvent mais c'est toi
je crois pas le truc je le connais pas
alors à moins que j'ai oublié que je
connaissais mais je pense il a bien
écrit tu vas bien sur vos conseils déjà
il te vouvoie donc ça c'est bien
si des grands nom du livre je suis très
content de leur conseiller mais je
conseille des livres que tu ne lis pas
donc mais je suis pas sûr ça moi
franchement oui vous en avez parlé ici
sur les commentaires en direct c'était
peut-être bac honnêtement je pense que
c'est pour quel niveau
Vlad m'a dit quand je lui ai montré que
tu as certains élèves à 26 50 qui
connaissent pas toutes les finales
malheureusement
donc je dirais de 1400 jusqu'à champion
du monde quand en tout cas faut voir les
lots d'Ali resa jusqu'à 25 93 je pense
donc de ouais 1300400 jusqu'à 27 80
il avait un élève à 26 50 il m'a dit
c'est sûr qu'il peut pas il a jamais vu
il connaît pas il m'a dit c'est grave
ici mais il m'a dit si tu savais si tu
connaissais leur niveau aujourd'hui
ok sympa
mais c'est que des trucs théoriques
importants
à la con tu rencontres jamais c'est que
des trucs que tu rencontres en partie
mais genre vraiment tu vois cette finale
là tu peux avoir en partie là
ok ça déjà
ils vont c'est facile ça reste facile
mais
là déjà tu vois
c'est la règle
je connais ça je connais ça je connais
tout mais elles sont à connaître
je pense
et ça c'est contre
celle là tu peux la montrer à l'écran je
l'ai gagné en blitz il y a pas longtemps
parce que je la connais j'ai fait le
livre
pour ceux qui regardent mes bits en
direct
ça là on a gagné il y a pas longtemps
et réellement ma rêve c'était l'exercice
de ce bouquin là que j'ai fait je suis
très heureux de la gagner et
moi je connais pas enfin donc je peux
avoir des idées pour faire mais
enfin c'est un plan tu vas pas la gueule
[Musique]
bon tu connaissais mais je vais repars
là que enfin c'était juste pour dire ma
rêve quand j'ai gagné cette finale
c'était ce truc là de ce livre là mais
bon c'est important de savoir
ça c'est la fameuse hallucine capable en
car tu vois
enfin en tout cas bon livre
parce que je vois je peux recommander
mais oui non c'est un bon
[Musique]
c'est un bon livre
c'est Bern Rosen attention le nom de
famille peut te faire penser que ça va
pas être un super livre mais oui ça fait
peur
1300400 non c'est plus pour 1800 2000
celui-là est bien pour 1300400
mais je l'ai mis mais là il y a pas mais
sur ma chaîne une petite recommandation
de bouquin personnel avec des liens mais
faut aller sur ma chaîne
mais il a vraiment eu raison de ne pas
aller dans la berlinoise
victoire
de toute façon mais
on l'a vu
ok bon ben
vous pensez que Nico va la gagner non
comme un fou c'est à dire qu'il
en fait il a joué cet ouverture mais
finalement maintenant il joue pas tout
pour le gars il prend pas de risque
après
[Musique]
il prend pas de décision pour pour être
plus mal mais mais que ça reste un peu
compliqué
il y a des gens qui mettent mes livres
qu'on sait pas le faire je conseille
quoi d'ailleurs pour les finales je
regarde mes propres conseils
le Rosen
jusqu'à
en fait j'écris dans les commentaires
que c'est au choix de rien qui a 19 €
le fondamental engine
ça doit être
ouais de Muller il est très bien
celui-là je sais pas non mais je connais
il est très bien en fait il est pour
tous et les sans fin connaître mais
c'est pour plus en fait c'est un peu
dans l'ordre
d'achat et plus de 2000 je recommande
quoi
votre
je pense que j'ai mis la chair et chef
ski
aussi c'est des cons qui ratent des
trucs quoi
tu es nul
et le chat
j'aime beaucoup les livres que j'ai
recommandé c'est magnifique mais bon
c'est logique en fait vraiment très fin
comme je sais pas qui est sorti
mais oui mais en fait je trouve qu'ils
sont enfin je pense si c'est assez huit
livres sur les finales et que tu les
connais
tu es imprenable
ça suffit quoi enfin je gère évidemment
il faut qu'on connaît beaucoup plus
normalement mais c'est un bon début ça
va largement toi par exemple dans ton
range mais ça suffit quand même
non mais ils sont bien ces livres
c'est la 13e partie aujourd'hui
plus que deux
tu recommandes
j'ai mis un ou deux bouquins
généralistes mais qui servent à rien
mais pour commencer mais sinon les
bouquins sur les ouvertures c'est
compliqué quoi en fait c'est
en fait
être super bien juste pas adapté donc là
c'est à chacun de voir
globalement tu as des bonnes maisons
d'édition
et des bons auteurs faut engin ne pas
prendre des mecs qui crient 50 livres
par an mais par exemple dans mon livre
sur la grue j'en suis assez déçu quand
même le mec est pas connu
c'est que des lignes d'ordi à la con
enfin envoie-moi un pgm
ah mais maintenant tu as beaucoup de
temps mais
[Musique]
mais oui non non faut prendre des
auteurs qu'on connaît quoi
[Musique]
moins de 2000 et lots
et alors deuxième truc malheureusement
pour les ouvertures c'est qu'il
vieillissent au bout d'un moment faudra
refaire par contre ça peut vraiment
donner
de l'inspiration quoi expliquer les
ventes qui existent tu savais pas tout
ce qui existe voilà les lignes etc mais
il fera pas toute une carrière quoi
où tu peux cliquer
et nous bientôt on va voir notre série
là qui va sortir la française facile un
répertoire
un répertoire complet en une heure et
quart Fab
ce qui est quand même agréable
est-ce que je viens d'acheter toujours
d'actualité Fab ça va mais aussi
mais globalement oui
comme tous les livres
mais
quoi non mais il est bien enfin ça va on
est tellement en avance pour l'époque et
c'est pas une ouverture qui est jouée
spécialement que que en fait ça va quoi
qui s'est passé ce bouquin qui a pris
deux semaines après sa sortie non mais
je crois que j'ai entendu que je suis
rafle avait pris
mais c'est bête de pas faire ces trucs
là en PGN parce que les gens volent mais
sinon de base c'est plus intéressant
quoi
chyprof tu veux dire théorie du [ __ ]
toujours
est-ce que tu conseilles ton coffret DVD
sur la pire qu'un
en fait tous les trucs que je fais
j'essaie de faire au mieux après la pire
que c'est pas pour tout le monde en fait
c'est le truc mais si vous voulez la
jouer je trouve c'est pas con après
ça peut ne pas être autosuffisant pour
le coup c'est bien de l'avoir
bossé à côté peut-être s'il y a une
ligne que je conseille et qui te plaît
pas parce qu'en fait je fais un
répertoire donc peut-être toi tu
préfères jouer un setup avec ces 6 B5
quand je parle de la 6 B5 ou un truc sur
l'attaque autrichienne que c'est pas le
problème mais en fait j'ai essayé de
faire sur ce DVD de la pire
en deux parties la moitié du DVD juste
je propose un répertoire et l'autre
moitié les thèmes qui peuvent exister la
pousse 5 pour les blancs les noirs qui
cassent le centre la stratégie pour
jouer sur les cases noires quand tu as
cassé le truc enfin donc tu vas bien
comprendre normalement plus ou moins les
enjeux et après tu as un répertoire mais
après c'est comme pour les livres à un
moment on est à toi et vieillissent
peut-être il y a une partie qui va
réfuter un truc ou quoi je sais pas mais
normalement tu auras compris le voilà
comment ça se joue
donc oui enfin je recommande enfin oui
non si tu as envie de jouer la pire que
je peux te dire oui
genre moi par exemple qui est pas envie
de jouer à la pierre
est-ce que tu me recommandes les livres
sur les finales si je veux pas
progresser en finale oui malgré tout
pas content ces personnes ne rentre dans
la sienne c'est le problème cela dit
il faudrait que tu puisses octroyer un
autre truc sur les siennes pas ouverte
ou un livre
ou tu kiffes au hasard quoi au bout d'un
moment
faut regarder les roses au niveau toutes
les semaines
complexe
mais du coup ça notre truc enfin on
pourrait faire un autre DVD sur ça mais
tu vois
on arrive sur le clic au hasard ça
serait magnifique quand même
en fait il y a pas de livre vraiment sur
les échecs pratiques
juste des positions pratiques
ouais j'ai peut-être un truc en plus
mais oui c'est assez rare
c'est même assez rare des livres avec
des positions plus ou moins égales et
que tu cherches des plans juste tu
cliques mais attends j'ai un truc pas
mal
je suis là
j'ai ça qui est complètement
exceptionnel
secret la stratégie moderne aux échecs
j'ai ça qui est très bien mais il est
dans le style du livre qu'on va sortir
nous qui est en train d'écrire Samy
ça c'est la chanson vraiment mais main
pour les amateurs
en fait c'est intéressant
je peux le montrer
non parce que c'est de la merde
mais qu'est-ce que c'est de la merde
c'est que des pièges en fait
mais je trouve que c'est une merde
j'ai ça qui est très bien mais qui est
recommandé pour des joueurs qui ont pas
niveau pour le lire
on a plus de place
le truc c'est que comme il y en a qui
était pas bon tu en veux pas faire de la
mauvaise pub non plus
c'est de la merde mais c'est bien en
fait il y a rien qui va mais c'est très
inspirant il te montre
d'ouverture à l'ancienne où on te met
juste des parties
par exemple ça j'arrive même pas à lire
en fait c'est les nouveaux livres c'est
que des [ __ ] de lignes d'ordi bon il
y a quelques parties des fois mais c'est
que
les lignes dans ta gueule
c'est bien mais c'est relou enfin moi ça
me fait chier ça me fait pas trop
progresser mais c'est bien sous les
lignes
Arthur à l'ancienne c'est un livre je
sais pas il a été écrit quand euh
des années 90 ouais
1998 Peter Wells qui est un excellent
joueur bah c'est les livres d'ouverture
à l'ancienne ou en fait tu as plein de
parties tu as des parties qui sont pas
trop analysées mais que tu peux regarder
et en fait et même aujourd'hui je
préfère largement
et en fait je lis les parties ah oui
[ __ ] j'ai revu ah tiens une partie de
carpatch même dedans machin ah tiens
d'autres chefs que je galère enfin
tu as perdu regarde tu es nul mais
toujours su et c'est analysé à fond et
tout et là non mais ça ça a gagné
vraiment une très mauvaise partie je
pense Murtas qui gagne avec les Noirs tu
imagines le niveau de jeu au blanc mais
c'est des bons [ __ ] de livre des
années 90 on te montre des parties et ça
te sur l'ouverture tu as les pièges
tactiques les machins les schémas
comparer au livre d'aujourd'hui j'en ai
marre en fait je suis énervé et ça
j'arrive pas à me faire un avis tu peux
le montrer on ne sait pas alors on ne
sait pas
il écrit beaucoup de livres donc sans
cesse de la merde Michel a un peu mangé
mais il y a des trucs intéressants je
suis mitigé il y a du bien et du moins
bien
comment tu veux travailler les positions
tu réfléchis jusqu'à trouver et donc tu
as pas trouvé tu continues ah bah oui ça
mais sinon qu'est-ce que tu veux faire
d'autre
sinon on se débarqué analyser donc tu
lis tu regardes ce qu'ils disent qui
conseille si un moment tu as envie de
faire une pause la position de son
intéressante moi j'aurais ça mais quand
je suis à plusieurs ça peut être une
demi-heure c'est pas juste tu cliques au
hasard en avançant la partie quoi donc
faut prendre du temps et un livre
d'échec en général tu peux pas le lire
comme ça clac clac clac comme un roman
quoi tu dois te poser sur une planche ou
sur un échiquier et
peut-être bouger les pièces etc après ce
qui est pas mal c'est que si c'est de
faire un peu de tête notamment peut-être
les variantes des trucs comme ça ça te
force à essayer de calculer avoir un peu
les coûts sans bouger donc améliorateur
un peu tes habitudes de calcul de
projection etc
voilà
cinquième
de 1927 à 1974
avec des petites histoires et tout ça
c'est des beaux livres à lire hein
je trouve jamais
une tour sur la 7e
Ning à parler de ça mais c'était sympa
merci pour voilà et puis du coup on est
parti
et le bouquin risque que tu aimes
beaucoup Kevin ah mais c'est de 20
matchs
qui ont été écrits par les joueurs et
tout ça c'est cool hein
enfin moi je suis très heureux
[Musique]
sur les photos que sur les parties
Freddie Mercury fume pendant la partie
c'est beau quoi
ça fume ça boit sur la table
c'est hyper étalé classement et tout
enfin tu vois Olympiades de 60 premier
URSS 34 points allez pique deuxième
États-Unis 29 fois troisième Yougoslavie
hein
finale ah non c'est final ah
la France Allemagne de l'Est
juste derrière l'Allemagne fédérale le
gros derby
et nous on était où en 60 ans
l'URSS aligne en 60 tal
bottes
corseneuil Smith et aussi si tu avais
juste petrosian
[Musique]
c'était pas mal
manquer les États-Unis c'était aussi pas
mal tu avais Fisher Lombardie
pour des raisons de prestige chaque pays
organisateur cherche à faire mieux que
son prédécesseur cette rivalité éclate
au grand jour lorsque les motivations
politiques s'y ajoute comme c'était le
cas entre Munich ellipsique
l'Allemagne de l'Est apporta un soin
accrue à l'organisation de cette
manifestation qui recueillit un nombre
record d'inscription 40 pays étaient au
rendez-vous y compris les États-Unis qui
s'étaient décidé à la dernière minute ce
retard s'expliquait non seulement par
les raisons politiques que l'on devine
mais aussi par les difficultés
rencontrées dans la formation de
l'équipe l'enfant prodige Fisher donc en
60 il est très jeune
occupé le premier tableau né en 1943
Chicago Bobby avait gagné à l'âge de 14
ans son premier championnat des
États-Unis un talent aussi précoce ne
s'était jamais rencontré dans l'histoire
des échecs en revanche très chefski le
premier tableau américain Munich n'avait
pas fait le déplacement ces exigences
financières 3000 dollars n'ayant pu être
satisfaite [ __ ] 3000 dollars en 60
000 balles aujourd'hui hein
l'équipe de l'URSS comprenait un nouveau
venu corseneuil et s'annonçait plus
forte que jamais elle gagna d'ailleurs
toutes ses rencontres quelques inconnus
firent sensations au cours des
éliminatoires à titre d'exemple citons
la victoire de Aaron le joueur indien
sur l'ex champion du monde le docteur
away et la défaite de Fisher face à
munios je leur ai quoi sans rien la
finale de Nadal a une grande bataille
entre les États-Unis et la Yougoslavie
pour les médailles d'argent et de bronze
l'équipe de Fischer enleva la seconde
place avec un écart de deux points à sa
faveur en marge du tournoi c'était
ouvert une exposition remarquable
intitulée les échecs à travers l'âge
et c'est tout
après il te montre une partie celle de
Fisher contre ouais mais tu vois moi je
kiffe tu vois un livre comme ça tu vois
pour moi c'est un kiff quoi
on a rien à [ __ ]
mais ça c'est des vrais livres d'échec
tu vois là je lis ça j'ai un kiffe tu
vois bon si vous voulez on pourrait
faire une séance on lit en fait on s'en
fout mais tu les trouves où c'est pas
c'est des vieux livres ça c'est livre tu
les tu sais même pas comment tu les
trouves quoi tu les as des fois dans des
brocantes des gens qui vendent des
livres mais en fait tu me prends ça ou
en fait est-ce que tu prends plus de
plaisir à lire ça semi cela vous a que
des varanes d'ordi pendant 300 pages où
ça un livre complètement rando mais d'un
mec des potes qui te parle qui parle
d'échec quoi
pour moi le choix est vite fait quoi
mais malheureusement on les échecs
maintenant il y a plus que des livres
comme ça qui sortent quasiment
en photo enfin je sais pas tu es heureux
non mais c'est les échecs à l'ancienne
c'est les échecs de café c'est les
échecs qu'on aime quoi c'est un chef qui
demande 3000 balles et qui vient pas
jouer non mais aujourd'hui
tu peux avoir des équipes
qui ont pas la meilleure joueur et les
mecs te disent pas que c'est un problème
d'argent tu vois c'est l'époque où les
mecs [ __ ] ils posaient leurs couilles
je joue pas parce que je peux pas j'ai
pas le temps j'ai piscine tiens les mecs
ils disent ok juste le fric je joue
aligné pas je joue pas enfin
c'est ouais c'est vrai c'est les époques
à l'ancienne ou les mecs posaient leurs
couilles sans arrêt sur la table quoi
c'est cool
non mais moi c'est une époque que j'aime
faim j'aime mieux lire là-dessus quoi
même s'il y avait du mauvais tu vois
fumer à la table et tout c'est bien que
c'était interdit mais bon c'est cool tu
vois un peu des trucs
à l'intérieur mais
quand j'étais petit donc d'échec ça fumé
le cigare je sais pas il est jamais le
cendrier il foutait toutes ses centres
sur la case à chat quoi tout le temps
c'est dégueulasse
puis c'est pas le problème mais tu as
des petites histoires comme ça en fait
la leçon de vie c'était la case à chien
quoi à chaque fois
incroyable quoi
d'un mec ça me fait penser avec les
trucs de cendrier et tout je sais pas un
mec qui se chauffe dans un bar et tout
avec le barman il est en train de fumer
et lui dire est-ce que tu peux un petit
peu baisser ta tête j'aurais besoin d'un
cendrier
elle fait très très mal celle-là non
mais non mais moi je préfère lire les
histoires comme ça je trouve que c'est
marrant c'est sympa
et tu as des beaux trucs
et tu as des belles parties
qui a gagné le prix de la plus belle
partie de l'olympiade voilà donc c'était
pas de la merde donc c'est pas en fait
il te met pas des parties de merde
il te met aussi les
on peut regarder
comme ça alors on est parti les plus
connes du truc là c'est Timan contre bac
Ali
baby
donc
super facile bah quand il est à fond
mais je pense à pas très bien se passer
pour bacali je la sens pas trop
bon abandonné déjà
[Musique]
avec les Blancs contre Cooper Pays de
Galles
qui est très chaud Rigo H4
un peu plus longue
c'est la partie
mais je sais pas je trouve c'est cool
comme lui c'est une petite partie à la
con comme ça moi ça me fait marrer tu
les regardes comme ça de tête aussi on
regarde le con c'est fait maintenant si
fou
c'est marrant et après et ça ah tiens il
fait une partie sur l'évolution de la
théorie face à un anniversaire de valeur
inférieure en ouvrant le grand maître
velimirovic et le Boré une construction
qui le domine parfaitement
et introduire une nouveauté qui ignorait
encore les rivaux de Reykjavik en 72
ah en fait il a amélioré
dans son match pour toujours irakien
il a il a amélioré spaski Richard
Fischer après tu as quoi tu as une
partie de carpov contre al-malade de
Jordanie
mais enfin c'est parti intéressant en
fait
après ils vont te mettre le
parti même pas c'est juste que il y a un
mec qui a fait la même connerie quoi
la grande finale tu vois là il te mette
carpes Western Union
Salou en 2008 peut-être
pas founzik
[Musique]
dégage
qui m'a donné une bonne idée d'ailleurs
sur ce fou à cette
contre
théorique attention la liste en passant
en revue la partie à votre le maître
international néerlandais riz et le
grand maître vétérinaire richesse qui ou
ce dernier se vit confronté à une
nouveauté due au mètre belge
ta gueule
j'étais battu
t'aurai contre l'auteur Schmidt
défense à l'échine
ils sont très heureux de torer
une vidéo mais
je peux lâcher un peu l'info il y a une
partie
quelques semaines ou mois avant entre
spaski avec les Blancs et carpes
qui de ce plan probablement dû
l'inspirer donc on va un peu investiguer
tout ça donc ça c'est une info
faut trouver par burly qui nous a lâché
l'info
d'abord on s'est dit tiens peut-être ça
peut être l'objet d'une vidéo
intéressante sur la genèse d'un plan
connu par tous qu'on a attribué à Karpov
mais en fait peut-être qu'il a juste
pour faire une petite série et faire
aussi la partie de maroxy rends-moi à
16h j'ai envie de dire
et après il le fait toutes les parties
je pense on peut la retrouver
mais
ouais donc c'est livre à l'ancienne ça
se lit bien après ça se trouve plus
c'est plus réédité et puis il y a plus
personne qui écrit le livre comme ça
un peu comme ça genre un livre que j'ai
bien aimé
là c'est un mec qui parle de sa vie
c'était
Ivan se call of sur sa carrière
et en fait il te raconte un peu quand il
y a déménagé machin nana il y a très peu
de parties dedans beaucoup de textes
mais c'est agréable en fait il te
raconte quand il buvait avec Timan en
analysant en même temps et qu'il avait
donné il a voulu essayer en partie je
crois que ça a pas trop marché
etc enfin tu as des petites anecdotes ou
quoi c'est assez cool
mais en fait moi je peux pas le faire je
vivais pas en fait cette époque c'est
enfin je pourrais le faire mais faut que
j'arrête tout ce que je fais dans ma vie
et mettre à faire ça enfin c'est un
travail en fait de faire quoi de
chercher les anecdotes de ma chambre
c'est pas c'est autre chose et puis ça
se fait plus les gens sont plus
intéressés par les trucs full théoriques
oui avec ça tu ne vas vraiment pas
progresser aux échecs les gens ils
lisent des livres d'échecs ils font des
échecs pour progresser c'est comme les
gens qui me cachent c'est beaucoup mieux
de regarder des parties longs que des
rapides parce que moi on progresse
toujours nul enfin je sais pas comment
dire c'est tu regardes pour t'amuser
pour te divertir mais même nous en fait
on regarde pour se divertir si on veut
progresser on fait des tactiques ou quoi
mais on restera toujours mauvais
bon après les deux peuvent avoir leur
place j'ai envie de dire mais
c'est vrai que c'est dommage de tout
chercher par le prisme c'est de gagner
du résultat ou de l'ouverture des
ordinateurs
qui est intéressantes
et en fait quand tu vois ça tu vois
aussi humainement ce que les gaps
peuvent voir ou pas voir ouais non c'est
sympa j'adore
beaucoup moins bien que maintenant en
fait
les gens vivent dans un shonen ouais
ouais c'est vrai
les gens vivent dans l'illusion qu'on
peut devenir bon à tout alors que
malheureusement
on vit dans un monde où on peut être bon
à rien quoi je sais pas comment dire
c'est tous les trucs sont tellement
fortes tellement professionnel faut
enfin être très fort très vite faut être
très fort très vite ouais et ce
spécialiser etc après non mais après
pour le plaisir on peut apprendre une
variante ou quoi mais faire que lire des
lignes d'origine
perso je prends plus de plaisir à lire
ça aussi
en fait même à notre niveau qui peut
vous paraître bon on a déjà perdu nos
illusions sur le fait qu'on soit bon
surtout Fabien d'ailleurs moi j'ai
encore un peu d'illusion mais oui tu as
perdu tes illusions
mais c'est devenu trop dur d'être bon
dans un domaine fin bon au point d'être
dans les meilleurs du monde dans
n'importe quel domaine il y a tellement
de concurrence et a tellement de gens
intelligents forts
tout à ça et encore et avoir
un très bon
tu vois au foot
le foot c'est terrible
que ça toute sa vie en fait
que toi et enfin tu peux rien faire en
fait
ouais son livre il est sympa ouais
malgré le peu de vues c'est relatif la
vidéo sur l'histoire du Gambie Marchal
on apprend plein de trucs bah elle est
génial cette vidéo mais ouais c'est
intéressant pas trop les gens quoi mais
la vidéo est fantastique je pense c'est
une de nos meilleures vidéos en fait
qui a kiffé qui joue maintenant la ligne
à l'ancienne il s'en fout
je t'ai vu comme comme les Cubains il y
a 100 ans
il a raison enfin je trouve ça génial de
faire ça
beaucoup d'appeler et peu délu ouais
c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas être élu
après plus important surtout les choses
comme les échecs c'est de s'amuser et de
voir du spectacle qu'est-ce qu'on s'en
fout sur la première la deuxième ligne
de l'ordi et
ça me fait penser qu'on a raté la pause
oh donc sur cette belle discussion on va
pouvoir partir sur une pause la partie
complètement égale ça devrait faire une
nulle petit à petit à toute à toute
bon bah les amis bon bah les amis on est
en train de se diriger vers la nul hein
pendant qu'on est parti en fait ça a pas
joué pendant un moment ils ont joué très
vite 3 4 coups là en fait ça a bloqué à
tourrage des 4 on s'est revenu et ça
échangeait F5 est-ce que 5 F4 et puis F4
donc la position un peu mieux pour les
blancs après je pense pas que Néo
veuille vraiment la pousser non enfin
bon il faut comme il veut comme il veut
mais ça va sûrement il faut absolument
que je vous fout 4 si je pense ce qui
est très logique attaque un peu la tour
voilà mais on va faire C3 a priori il y
a peut-être mettre la tour en E8 ah
quoique alors pour bloquer 8
et du coup peut-être foutais un pour
pousser de en vrai
ah bon ça peut faire nul comme ça en
fait
c'est les blancs qui peuvent jouer s'ils
veulent et s'ils veulent pas ils veulent
pas et après il veut pas trop mais voilà
excellent choix de rapporte quand même
d'avoir pris le risque de gagner avec
les noirs
mais bon il va pas jouer
il va remporter les candidats
à mon avis n'est pas
au début du live que
[Musique]
c'était pas une super idée
mais il a pas eu la moindre chance de
gagner c'est juste fatigué pour demain
pour rien et les pots pour être plus
méchant s'il en ville là je vais plus
longtemps quoi
je sais pas peut-être c'est vrai
je pense qu'il a pas trop abusé non plus
Richard non mais après il a pas joué de
coupe il a juste une ouverture mais il a
pas il a pas pousse à n'importe quoi
il a arrêté au bon moment
tu peux faire
ça
le petit ventre de nez pas je vais pas
je vais de ce pas manger un gâteau
normal
j'ai mon téléphone qui sonne
mettre deux Chazelles qui disent que
vous pensez que mes pots
peut perdre exprès de ma très vite pour
tricher non s'il faudra qu'il attend de
la remise des prix qui aura lieu je
pense le jour d'après et il a pas envie
de donner ses points à la poubelle donc
il va pas faire et demain il va juger
normal et si si nous le Rapid il sera 13
heureux si ça joue bah ça jouera une
partie sans enjeu l'an dernier il avait
perdu la partie sans enjeux contreding
mais je pense cette année pourrait
changer ça si tu viens toi sans défaite
c'est un beau petit challenge donc je
pense pas qu'il va jouer risquer il va
et si Douda est bien d'accord pour faire
une petite nul demain ça va pas le gêner
quoi
ce qu'on peut aller voir du Rapido s'il
passe à côté salut ça va dans le chat
parce qu'il se passe c'est que une
épaule on devrait faire nul et lui
assurer mathématiquement la victoire
radebov Carona il y a une huile bonne
prépa de carbone à qui qui a su museler
la Catalane de Raja BOV fearuja contre
Ding bon ça reste cette finale légale
alors il y a certains pions de plus pour
les blancs mais il faut tout le reposer
bien bloquer on va pas trop comment
avancer dans ce genre de de position
donc bon ça peut tourner longtemps mais
nul semble acté et enfin la partie entre
Naka et Douda donc la plus intéressante
au final
pas clair en fait ma cave a une
superposition
enfin super on sait pas parce qu'on
n'est pas passé trop de temps dessus
mais assez vite avec ce roi des roquets
etc
ce qui avait dit qu'il allait pouvoir
rester rester pendant incruster en G6
qui organise les Noirs parce qu'on sait
que cette colonne ouverte normalement ça
aurait été bien point noir de mettre une
tour dessus peut-être le cavalier qui
vient là ça c'est des plans qui existent
plus mais je vois que Douda a su se
mettre en place
notamment avec cette manœuvre de
cavalier qui vient chasser celui-là donc
Naka il a pas eu envie d'échanger lequel
il repart et pas n'importe où il va
venir là pour prendre le pion et n'a
qu'à la donnera peut-être ce coup de
calage 4 t'es pas le meilleur j'en sais
rien faudrait analyser un peu mieux
toujours est-il que ce qu'on voit ici
c'est que non gagné un pion
alors certes c'est toujours pas clair
mais la situation c'est grandement
amélioré en tout cas donc voilà allez
retourne chez les pots parce que c'est
ça qui
qui joue pour le pour le gain du tournoi
alors la position après tour des 8
bizarre j'ai l'impression qu'il a joué
mais j'ai pas reçu le coup il a fait
foudre
et puis peut-être jouer une finale ou un
trois contre deux ici c'est sans risque
pour les blancs parce que le 3 contre 2
des noirs allez le roi finalement il est
bloqué à cause de la structure de pions
donc il se dit bah tiens si je peux
échanger je monte le roi je pousse mes
pions petit à petit je crains puis en
passer comme ça et
après ce qu'on avait regardé c'était
quoi c'était
genre un coup
ça parce que en cas d'échange on peut
prendre avec la tour et là évidemment si
on prend les remet en place et si on
recule en fait ce roi est passif par
rapport à celui-là donc les Noirs là ont
des chances clairement c'est eux qui ont
créé le ton passe en premier ils ont le
droit actif qui va venir ici donc ça
c'est mal joué par des Blancs faudrait
pas faudrait pas échanger donc peut-être
un coup comme roi là je dis une connerie
c'est prise resto 2
[Musique]
un coup x j'ai peut-être les Noirs il
peut attendre et on revient et il
pourrait faire une petite nulle comme ça
disons donc normalement oui ça va pas
durer trop longtemps à mon avis
mais bon
3 mondiale après les candidats bah
écoute il fallait regarder sur le site
du classement live 2700 live et je pense
que oui a priori mais
je ne veux dire ça
en ce moment il est déjà niveau 3
mondial
il est déjà en fait
et très largement c'est à dire que lui
numéro 3 avec 279 enfin 792.6 et carwana
il y a 2780 donc il y a 12 points
d'écart il va pas les perdre entre
aujourd'hui et demain
donc voilà il sera troisième après digne
il a toujours 2804 on se fait 12 points
d'avance pareil donc il devrait être
numéro 3 mondial à coup sûr après
après le tournoi
donc voilà après c'est pas une grande
journée d'échec bon rapporte que j'ai
une ouverture pour pas faire nul en 10
coups en 5 minutes comme hier mais ça
change pas grand chose je dois dire
à combien je peux vous dire sur le
classement live en tournant pour
l'instant les derniers et au classement
live il perd pas mal fieron il perd 20
points et l'eau il est à 2773 numéro 6
mondiale
voilà alors hyper un petit peu plus pour
même passer derrière saut qui a 2773
comme lui actuellement voilà il sera
6/6/7 ou 5e mondial à la fin des
candidats quoi
c'était notre fameux micro qu'on a reçu
pour la fin
pour le Championnat du Monde
c'est bien ils sont arrivés
parler dedans
il faut se mettre près il faut tout le
temps parler fort
mais finalement être une bonne solution
de remplacement avec ce micro ça va le
casque sur la tête sur la tête
on pourra tester demain pour faire de
l'entraînement ah bah oui c'est de la
vidéo YouTube ce soir
on verra le temps qu'il faut pour le
monter ou quoi c'est peut-être pas le
moment
c'est quand le champion du monde mais on
pense en mars enfin je sais pas à quel
point ça annonce officiel ou pas mais
ils vont jouer un peu
ouais
c'est moins bien que ce que c'était
[Musique]
je crois qu'il veut
pas faire roi des deux c'est de faire
froncer deux taureau 2 prendre 4 fait
tout reprendre
mais si tu veux gagner
tellement rien à dire c'est dur
en fait on attend juste que ça se
finisse quoi
on peut pas faire beaucoup plus
je crois que c'est vendeur qui a gagné
l'étape mais Mathieu va nous confirmer
comment ça s'appelle
Dylan grenovegen c'est quoi cette
Fabio Jacobsen complète le podium Peter
Sagan 4e
Peter
je sais pas ce vainqueur là
les candidats qui ont en train de se
sont en train de se terminer
ouais peut-être juste fou B3
tourner cette retour et pousser de ça
paraît vraiment être la manière la plus
clean de faire nul Fab allez mon épaule
oui mon gâté
chemise blanche veste bleue bien sûr
qu'ils l'ont raté
soleil petite nul shifter pro
je sais pas je crois qu'il veut vraiment
le punir
non ça va proposition tacite de nul pour
Yann
qui va se lever il se barre il en a
absolument rien à [ __ ] c'est
magnifique
on va les mettre en grand plan Fab
voilà gros plan sur sur Richard
c'est trop attendez 8 ou c'est un tour
des 7 poussée de tout recette et là ça
devrait répéter
je sais pas trop à quoi il réfléchit en
fait
il fait tomber
the way from the dro
poussez-le ça répète Fab on est en train
de vivre le couronnement de Yann et
pomyachi dans ce tournoi des candidats
lui qui retournera un défi l'ogre Magnus
Carlsen au championnat du monde il a
peur de rien des pots il avait pris la
douche froide dans son premier duel pour
un titre de champion du monde mais il a
encore les crocs il a encore les dents
il a envie d'y retourner et ce qui sera
capable de faire vaciller cette fois-ci
Magnus Carlsen de son piédestal
où est-ce que sera une nouvelle défaite
il demande la nul Richard on appelle
l'arbitre quand même pour vérifier mais
là les deux joueurs de toute façon le
veulent donc si ça paraît péter trois
fois il continue bravo
le tournoi des candidats est terminé les
amis Yann et pomyachi qui a écrasé de
ton tournoi de son empreinte ne laissant
aucune place assez concurrents et en
remportant ce tournoi avec le score
magnifique de 9 points Fabien 13 sur 13
résultat historiques ah bah si en plus
demain sur 14 sera le plus haut score
dans ce format là dans l'histoire des
candidats dans ce format il suffit plus
de fermer le thermos et de rentrer dans
sa chambre d'hôtel il sent même pas
heureux ils savaient qu'il avait gagné
le tournoi il est juste tranquille
serein peut-être le suivant à la caméra
ou il va partir dans le sens on va voir
dans quel sens il part si part vers la
gauche on va pouvoir le suivre si par
vers la droite c'est déjà terminé pour
nous il va rendre les feuilles de parti
est-ce qu'il va ranger les pièces même
même pas il pose et franchement il s'en
va tout droit il s'en va tout droit Yann
ah victoire éclatante dans ce tournoi
qu'il amené du début à la fin dès la
première onde il a pris la tête il ne
l'a jamais rendu attaque au kilomètre
zéro et
Floyd Landis
ailleurs
on l'a perdu non on l'a perdu mais je
pense qu'il a dû traverser autrement en
fait
en tout cas dans ces candidats qui sont
terminés c'est l'information à 17h33
les candidats sont terminés
bravo nepo
pourquoi les autres contient un jeu bah
on continue à jouer pour savoir qui
finit 5e 6e 7e c'est intéressant quand
même ça joue encore les les places
d'honneur avec un enjeu fantastique de
savoir qui sera sixième ou 7e des
candidats donc encore un peu de jeux
pour la deuxième troisième place aussi
bon bah il clique
donc on va se mettre sur cette partie je
sais pas si tu veux faire une petite
pause frappe après ces émotions après
ses émotions et ce résultat annoncé
cette victoire de Yann nepomashi dans
les candidats
on peut on peut
souffler on peut souffler quand même
squelette a eu des tu as eu quand même
un une émotion là qui était venu
puissante quand même exactement
donc
à tout de suite
il nous reste encore un petit peu
d'échec à suivre quand même pour pour le
plaisir des belles parties c'est vrai
que on sent la SPA
je pense qu'on a rien fait contre des
quatre en fait non
on va vous proposer
un répertoire mais bon faut encore venir
à Lisbonne
mais en fait Fiero gaffe maintenant
j'ai pas trop ce qui s'est passé à tout
moment il peut perdre
ce serait beau en quelque sorte
on en est loin mais bon
forcément une place pour le champion du
monde si non mais enfin on l'a pas
oublié depuis deux semaines mais il
viendra jouer toute façon donc
t'inquiète
5 minutes par jour avec juste sur 5
minutes on l'a pas dit oui peut-être on
va pas répéter en boucle le même truc
mais c'est à suivi
[Musique]
il y a karouana il y a Nakamura elle est
partie prenante tout le monde sait qui
va jouer en fait
ou alors si quelqu'un qui a une mémoire
de poisson rouge que je crois que les
poissons rouges ont un truc comme
6 ou 6 ou 7 secondes de mémoire
j'aime vraiment que ce qui vient de se
passer
non mais pour se préparer des fois ouais
il y avait des parties d'entraînement
pour tester avec ton équipe un peu sur
un secret pour tester les ouvertures des
choses comme ça
et donc justement le but c'est que ça se
crée
il donne une option qui n'avait pas vous
voyez pas trop arriver de prime abord du
coup peut-être faire sacrifier de fou
contre les deux pions les deux punch
enfin je sais pas moi qui va faire un
blocage mais bon ce pion qui est en D3
quand même
donc il va falloir donner une pièce et
puis bah après moi je sais pas trop ce
que ça donne genre position bien
compliqué tout d'un coup quoi
mais je vois mal les blancs je vais pour
gagner que leurs trois pions s'ils sont
bloqués sur tous les fronts il y aura
pas droit F3 G4 tu seras bloqué sur les
cases à l'aile dame
[Musique]
je sais pas j'imagine un truc comme
tourner un des trois sacrifices échecs
trois bouches C4 et donc de toute façon
avec les Clément tu as jamais
[Musique]
je sais pas si on sait six ou aussi
admettons c'est 4 bon ça je sais pas si
énorme peuvent avancer mais en tout cas
avec les Blancs c'est sûr que non quoi
vraiment eu raison aujourd'hui de forcer
le gain avec les Blancs femme c'est
vraiment pour l'amour des échecs
pragmatique malgré ce que pense le chat
ça devrait aller pour les tu dois
travailler alors
tu peux juste faire nul comme ça et tu
vas à force aux échecs si jamais une
bonne idée
bon tu peux aller voir sur les fédés
nationales de enfin du site des fédé de
chaque pays après sur le site de la file
un truc
et
c'est pas évident avant il y avait un
site auquel j'étais abonné c'était
cheesmix mais il y a moins d'infos
qu'avant après tu as chest calendar
ouais
mais en fait je suis là en fait
que tu fasses 2 et que tu fasses nul
quand même
mais après c'est sûr que à partir du
moment où il fait ces trois
même là ça a toujours
mais on en est là non ça peut être super
agréable pour faire ce qui se passe
hyper ça au blanc quand même c'est
extraordinaire
perdre cette finale au blanc il faut
quand même le vouloir
pas rien faire c'est possible mais bon
les finales
mais derrière truc marrant c'est que si
tu as la même position avec le pion des
trois il y a déjà tout reprend B5 je
pense et E3 non
ah ok tu as réussi encore à t'en sortir
comme ça
mais bon
mais tu es déjà pas loin
c'est dangereux
ça va faire nul quand même encore mais
bon
et Caro il commence à être mal
mais il a perdu le numéro 4 en fait
du coup
mais après je comprends
psychologiquement d'après ce que des
gens ont dit nous on avait pas la cam
sur Hikaru au moment de la nul mais il
paraît psychologiquement ça lui a mis un
coup de quoi que Yann
je peux comprendre aussi c'est juste tu
perds tes dernières microscopiques
illusions
oui tu perds
je le comprends complètement
même si tu le sais avant la ronde là tu
sais que et puis surtout quoi il lui
comme il a dit en stream il n'y croit
pas du tout à Magnus
complexe
j'entends regarder une interview de
mais il répond pas à Magnus en fait s'il
va jouer au bar il y a Sardoche en fait
qui demandait il va d'ici il joue pas
mais là il répondait un truc une
interview juste après la victoire de
nepo il te dit pas s'il va jouer le
match enfin moi je trouve ça hallucinant
en fait de ce flou mais même de la part
de la fille en fait de le laisser enfin
juste sa nuit tellement au sport et tu
vois ça se voit dans les chats partout
et ce qui va jouer
c'est pas normal en fait mais bon
il y a encore une fois c'est absolument
rien contre Magnus c'est à la fille de
s'imposer et dire bon bah bon
après B5
du coup tu as tout mal quand même le kg
6 qui est bien en fait il décore plus
qu'autre chose parce qu'il attaque rien
en fait
c'est hyper insultant pour nepo et tous
les autres enfin non j'avais pas ça
comme ça mais oui c'est pas respectueux
du sport en général et
et des moyens des sponsors et des gens
qui s'embêtent à moyen de passer le
tournoi c'est un mec qui aurait pu être
second et prendre tout le reste pour
revenir ou se dire tiens
bah ça change un truc quoi et même là à
la fin de confirmer ou d'infirmer il y a
bon vous avez déclaré ça est-ce que vous
allez jouer ou pas et juste
même dans la recherche des sponsors pour
les gens qui voudraient organiser le
truc et tout je peux pas
au même endroit
etc
disons que ça aurait été bien que c'est
streaming immédiatement la nettoie a
gagné qui se manquait je joue enfin il y
aura un match revent ou pas et parce que
là du coup ça laisse aussi tout le côté
médiatique tu vois ou nous on pourrait
dire ah bah tiens ce sera de nouveau
caresser donc quoi faites là tu sais pas
quoi bon bah quand même le dire mais
ce qui joue est-ce qu'ils jouent pas
enfin ça va être insupportable alors
c'est juste mon intime conviction qui va
jouer moi aussi
une conviction de sur vraiment je vois
pas d'autres exemples dans dans d'autres
sports où les gens font ça
peut-être les mecs en box qui je sais
pas mais bon la box c'est différent
c'est différent c'est très différent
j'ai pas dit la box de toute façon c'est
pas des modes de tournoi des trucs comme
ça puisque tu peux pas te combattre tous
les jours et te mettre sur la gueule je
crois que tu as besoin d'au moins 6 mois
après mais oui moi je pense que c'est
mieux qui joue quoi
il peut aussi vouloir arrêter au sommet
de son art
ouais au foot ça ressemble un peu avec
Nissan au foot
que ça ouais c'est dans le même style et
c'était dégueulasse qui avait fait
l'équipe de France j'avais détesté à
cette époque là
il avait déjà lancé qu'un jour est
probablement pas il était oui mais fait
là c'est toujours pas en fait si je joue
pas
mais oui c'est un peu du même style que
ouais que cette équipe de France moi
j'avais pas du tout aimé ce qu'il
t'avait fait je croyais que c'était
irrespectueux pour
l'équipe de France qui était venu pour
les supporters
je sais même plus
tu peux comparer le collectif à
l'individuel de temps en temps mais
parce que là avec le foot c'est plus
pareil là c'est pas enfin ouais c'est
différent
les revendications un petit Domenec
ouais mais enfin
qu'ils avaient viré du groupe c'est un
truc qui était sorti dans la presse etc
mais bon
en fait c'est pas
c'est vrai que ça c'est un autre
problème c'est vrai quand les clubs
payent des joueurs ou une ligue c'est
autre chose se barrent autre chose
est-ce que Toulouse gagne pas le
championnat de France cette année le
Brennus s'ils ont l'équipe tout le temps
on peut se poser la question mais bon
enfin bref mais là non c'est assez
singulier ce que fait Carlsen et surtout
le fait qu'il laisse le flou en fait tu
pourrais dire ça dans une conférence de
presse et puis après que bah il y a
quelqu'un qui te repose la question mais
là la fuite ils ont même pas les
couilles de la lui demander je sais pas
tu le prends sur un interview vous jouez
ou pas et puis en fait chacun se fait
son avis s'il répond pas ben ils ont pas
envie de savoir d'ailleurs mais c'est
bizarre de pas dire les choses quoi
comme elles sont
c'est peut-être juste du marketing
tu vas faire il va trouver un filou
il va sacrifier
voilà les noirs
qui viennent nous faire un petit un
petit fou prendre c'est le moment en
fait parce que si tu le fais pas
maintenant avec on descendre tu auras
plus l'occasion est-ce que tu prends la
plupart des chèques
donc c'est maintenant ou jamais une
raison de pas jouer peut-être qu'il en a
marre de jouer mais bon moi le truc que
j'ai enfin que j'aime pas trop en fait
il veut pas jouer parce qu'il aime pas
le format mais il propose pas
d'alternative
j'ai jamais trois apprécié quand tu
disais j'aime pas je vais pas faire et
quand tu dis mais je sais pas bon bah du
coup
on rentre dans la ligne
entre eux si c'est C6
il est devant
et ces quatre va être joué ensuite par
le problème c'est quand on a échangé les
tours
en fait
en fait cette finale là il se trouve
qu'elle doit être nulle non ou pas tu
dois pouvoir stand il n'y a pas de casse
d'entrée pour le roi
et pourquoi l'ordi tu gagnes
je t'avoue que j'ai pas la refaire
et tu recommences et tu gagnes
mais oui ça suffit
j'ai arrêté de regarder la ligne de leur
dire
j'ai 7 ans je sais pas pourquoi faudrait
faire mais bon
on sait pas
bon mais du coup
et moi tu vois j'ai arrêté
et du coup où est-ce que tu mets la tour
D7 te retournes
x refrain pour des 7 donc 3
il y a des trucs
bon c'est vrai que tu bouffes tous les
pions un moment tu vas être bien
[Musique]
bon ok ça doit aller
ça devrait faire nul
aussi échec dans son sens et pas
vraiment non il est quand même bon il
est bon mais il domine pas il est perdu
contre
c'est ça qui domine d'ailleurs sur
dominer
cette 6 sort des trois
maisons
pas encore faire comme ça
sinon en interne est écrasé depuis un
moment par musero lui-même écrasé par
encore une autre Ia plus généraliste
s'est trompé mais ouais c'est quand même
ça a l'air quand même assez con comme
coup
s
peut-être pourquoi pas
après
on nous leur dit ici en tout cas ils
veulent pas
d'accord
il attaque des 6 donc il va provoquer B4
il va repartir d'où il est au moins il a
géré le problème sur C4 mais
c'est pas très bien quand même ça a
cassé 5 avis pour les Noirs il est
plutôt foutu quoi en fait
bizarre ça partit très mauvaise
durant
du coup ça pourrait mettre Ding deuxième
mecs dans tout le temps non plus de 50 %
les dignes demain il a les blancs contre
fearuja ah non ce qui est en train de
jouer
[Musique]
match on verra bien ce sera pas mauvais
match mais
juste sur Apple meilleur joueur du monde
en fin de champion du monde ça dépend si
Magnus arrête les échecs oui si Magnus
continue et que ça ce match là va
falloir vraiment enfin moi ça fait des
années que je le dis mais on va encore
m'expliquer qu'il faut pas réformer que
tout va bien c'est c'est terrible en
fait
mais là ça va commencer à
le Fanta le douceur
ça fait plaisir ce petit fondant mais
c'est sûr qu'il a un truc avec Fanta oui
oui
je sais pas ce serait bien ça serait
bien
de l'organisme ce match
après ce que les Chinois n'ont vraiment
quelque chose à faire des échecs ils ont
tellement rien à faire que ouais mais
bon c'est un truc historique pour avoir
un champion du monde pourquoi pas quoi
ce serait bon un champion du monde c'est
pas si ils ont Ding pour que tu
organiserais pas jusqu'en Russie
c'est-à-dire compliqué d'organiser des
choses ouais ouais
en Inde pourquoi ce match après je sais
pas non moi je franchise serait cool
en réalité il y a très peu de marques
[Musique]
un peu tout quoi genre
une bouteille d'eau
il y a beaucoup de naissés dans le piège
c'est ça
pour ça qu'on attend B4 et le four
recule et après peut-être que c'est 5
gaz à vie on a dit puis à 4 à la
structure
la position des blancs et
non non
un gros truc et en fait c'est Nestlé
beaucoup de chance que ce soit d'un
homme ou Nestlé
est-ce que ça donne un peu sur la
cagnotte pas beaucoup et moi qui ai
donné je remets le lien pour ouais
c'est ça
[Musique]
en fait
donc n'hésitez pas et pas beaucoup de
gens qui ont bon on a un peu chauffé
quoi
elle a gagné
et ce serait pour l'aider à essayer de
trouver un traitement et voilà
ça avance pas de maisons 300000 ouais
bah oui c'est sûr que c'est beaucoup
ça joue
ils vont faire nulle dingue
ou pas
la jouer il va être obligé de faire
que des nuls comme nous et tu as des
gens qui veulent jouer à fond quoi mais
l'école des nuls n'est pas et tout quand
même pas mal quand même pas mal ouais
beaucoup de nuls aujourd'hui ah bah oui
voilà la petite nulle qui va être signée
et ben ça fait plaisir il va rester plus
qu'une partie les seuls qui ont pas
voulu faire nul
ils vont être puni
candidats oh que oui mais là c'est beau
les petites nuls ça par contre
c'est beau donc on a plus qu'une partie
en cours
pas très bien mais ça va jouer longtemps
non ou un truc comme ça
a pas fini avant le 40e donc il y aura
le rajout de temps
que moi jusqu'à 20h je pense
je sais pas pourquoi je suis tellement
Jean-Christophe
B4 mais qui enfin c'est pas tellement
évident un truc comme ça j'en sais rien
est-ce que tu es si contente dame quoi
donc il fait B4 TC5 j'aurais dit moi
pierre
mais bon c'est compliqué oui non mais tu
vas pas gagner tout de suite faut en
mettre en place
chaîne de pion des blancs peut-être
jouer sur la Colona regardez les persos
au centre un jour etc mais après Becca
ouais
franchement
la tATu qui saute ouais ça a l'air
logique mais bon il a raison de prendre
le temps c'est compliqué comme position
quand même
bravo né pour en tout cas c'est l'info
de la journée on s'y attendait c'est pas
une surprise on savait depuis un moment
qu'il allait gagner sophistes le truc
Sophie
on commentera quand même demain Fab ce
serait dommage de se priver du plaisir
de voir une dernière partie
je sais pas tout peut se passer ça va
être compliqué mais même Mikao pourrait
finir par gagner cette partie du coup là
autant dans l'autre tu es écrasé et
peut-être tu sauves une nulle si tu as
un miracle là
mais le fait qu'il réfléchissent
longtemps ça a annoncé une dingue non
en tout cas ça prépare pour le match
contre Carlson était ultra solide pour
qu'elle fasse 9 points aux candidats
comme quoi c'était que du mental après
c'est pas la même chose non plus Magnus
non mais après dès qu'il en a perdu une
il a été mis à la difficulté pour
exploser alors que la personne a pu le
faire exploser c'est un myther c'est un
peu comme autour de France quand il en
reste deux trois bah en fait tu es dans
les routes tu tiens bien puis à un
moment donné bah tu as pogaccha il te
fait exploser j'ai en fait à vrai dire
tant qu'il y avait pas fait gacharte
c'était le plus fort et puis et puis tu
te fais exploser quoi
avec les Blancs qu'on te rapporte qui
est nul donc ça officialise le sacre de
l'épaule sa qualification pour le
championnat du monde
fearuja dingue aussi
donc ouais ce coup D5 complication bon
bah l'idée énorme c'est de d'ouvrir la
colonne C pour rentrer avec la tour mais
prix d'un pion quoi donc d'ailleurs on
vient de le prendre et on s'attend à ce
que
Douda réplique par tour C2 attaquant la
lame sur quoi après il y aura plusieurs
options bouger la dame ou faire un petit
coin intermédiaire comme D6 c'est
pourquoi pas ouf des 6 d'ailleurs
machin il veut peut-être faire ça quoi
mais bon on peut prendre lui se bat
tre en fait qui sont très chaud quoi
qu'en cas de prise il y a la dame qui
débarque l'auteur qui démarre
[Musique]
chaud ça
c'est deux ce qui fait des sites
intermédiaires il fait fouder 6
intermédiaires parce que
je sais pas c'est très tendu et là tout
peut se passer en fait ça peut
finalement vite
d'un côté ou l'autre
position très complexe il reste 23
minutes avec carreaux 16 à Doodle 34e
ils ont le temps mais avoir quoi
tellement longtemps le match au titre on
va tellement se faire chier
ouais après le match en soi peut être
aussi très chiant tant que ce sera pas
réformé on se fera chier j'ai envie de
dire bon on est très dépendant du
contenu des parties
et ouais mais on a aussi souvent
dans les parties parce que perdre c'est
grave donc on a rarement des grandes
envolées quoi
c'est candidat ils ont quand même été
pas mal même si c'était rien de spé non
mais le contenu est parti iron animé
on va dire que les joueurs avec le
format qu'on leur impose ils ont offert
un spectacle correct c'est dur de faire
mieux avec ce qu'on leur propose
c'est comme sur liggs qui font les
règles ne joue pas au jeu mais alors en
fait si ce qu'ils font les règles jouent
au jeu mais il regarde pas ce qu'ils
font en fait
c'est des anciens joueurs qui peuvent
toujours jouer mais qui sont plus
et qui ont leur vision bien à eux et qui
regardent pas trop ce qu'on pense le
public les audiences qui regardent même
pas les compétitions qui créent en fait
en réalité regarde même pas ils ont
jamais passé une part une journée
entière devant les parties c'est sûr
mais en gros je pense que l'histoire ça
pourrait être s'ils peuvent pas toucher
aux règles du jeu
d'échecs des centaines d'années mais du
coup ils te ils te font quand même les
formats sans y toucher quoi sans y jouer
c'est un peu triste
c'est pas très grave de toute façon
après de toute façon toi aussi un grand
décalage entre les joueurs de top niveau
et les amateurs par exemple on a eu ma
thème entreprise on a eu des interviews
et moi je moi aussi je pense ça qui sont
très heureux de jouer au 960
c'est pas les ouvertures donc ça
m'intéresse pas c'était hyper
intéressant je regarde pas donc des fois
même des trucs intéressants
c'est complexe en fait
après il y a les cadences à changer mais
ça il le feront jamais je pense enfin
les gens qui sont à place actuellement
le font pas et maintenant les opposants
politiques à la figue là les trucs que
j'ai lu c'est désespérant aussi ça
ferait la même chose des gens différents
mais la même chose quoi en fait leur
seul truc le seul truc qui va le faire
avancer dans les échecs c'est la
transparence
de quoi dans les choix politiques et
tout mais ça parle pas de vision pour
les échecs ça dit juste à son des Russes
qui sont à la tête il faut des
bon après ils veulent plus de
transparence entre les fonds
ils ont aucun aucun programme dans ce
que j'ai lu il y a aucun programme pour
rendre les échecs plus populaires genre
ça tout le monde s'en fout c'est pas le
truc main
donc ça évoluera pas qui qui que ce soit
qui gagne en fait ça vaut mieux pas il y
a pas un programme
dont l'intérêt pas de gens qui se
présentent pour rendre les échecs plus
attractifs pour le public
c'est ça en fait vous regardez que pour
votre enfant mais le jeu en lui-même il
est intéressant quoi
genre moi je peux regarder des trucs je
sais pas je regarde du foot je joue pas
au foot
après
au sérieux en gros mais le truc c'est
que c'est la 4 à 5 c'est pas la même
position que les échecs c'était
peut-être utile dans la position c'est
pas de quelle partie tu parles mais faut
c'est plus les mêmes standard
actif donc c'est l'an 1 faire à 4 à 5
c'est très bien en fait
toi dans ton coin
le cœur du problème que je suis un peu
sur Twitter c'est défoncé suite à ce qui
est devoir Covic mais
à vrai dire sur ce qu'il dit il a pas
forcément tard ou enfin chacun son point
de vue c'est pas c'est pas ça la
question mais le problème c'est que j'ai
toujours détesté en politique enfin
surtout dans les échecs c'est plus à ça
que je me je m'intéresse c'est juste de
défoncer l'adversaire mais de pas
proposer de solution de faire que du
négatif en fait et de rien proposé
et je trouve ça tellement dommage si
t'as pas de programme
l'idée c'est pas de dire comment on va
faire mieux les échecs ils sont vraiment
très mauvais ça on lui demande de cons
oui mais toi tu veux faire quoi non eux
regarde pire que moi oui bon on sait pas
ça
peut-être mais en fait c'est cool
enfin je trouve que la logique ce serait
de spray enfin d'avoir envie de faire
quelque chose de bien pour les échecs
quoi
en premier lieu
mais ouais c'est que ça
c'était d'enfermer celui-là de menacer
B4 en fait puisque la case là elle est
prise la Casa elle est prise alors on a
vu que peut-être il y avait des
histoires avec la dame le plus on prend
ou je sais pas quoi mais en tout cas
faire [ __ ] des 6 ça règle
définitivement le problème il est plus
enfermé dame prend fou dame prend tout
donc c'est pas bon et du coup quand il
va prendre prendre il va prendre a
priori on peut avoir cette finale là moi
je préfère les blancs de loin parce
qu'il y a des raisons de maths contre le
roi
tu as plus de moins d'attaques B5
d'attaque 5 tu attaques tout alors
l'ordi a priori il te met une vente de
0-0 mais bon plutôt dangereux pour les
nord-est Thomas de jouer de la part de
dos
il est pareil aussi à la fatigue
du coup cette partie elle est faite
c'est la plus intéressante parce qu'il
se fasse des trucs mais elle est mal
jouée de part et d'autre c'est la
fatigue l'attention le manque d'enjeu
enfin voilà ça s'explique
le minimum sur les parties de Jamy avec
plaisir bah écoute moi je peux te
prendre l'exemple acheter Catalans quand
j'ai commenté le championnat du monde de
Blitz il y avait plein de gens qui
regardaient dans le chat il y a plein de
gens qui savaient à peine déplacer les
pièces et qui disait on a passé un super
moment c'était super on a kiffé etc donc
non je pense pas qu'il faille forcément
vraiment bien jouer aux échecs pour
apprécier les parties et le championnat
du monde de Blitz c'est un très bon
exemple où les où il y a plein de gens
qui sont venus qui savaient je
connaissais juste se déplacement des
pièces et qui jouait très rarement et
qui ont passé un excellent moment à
suivre à suivre le championnat donc
non on peut on peut jouer à peine aux
échecs et prendre du plaisir devant un
spectacle après faut qu'il ait un peu
dangereux des choses bien sûr
mais c'est pas obligatoire
et surtout le format cyprès de plus
évidemment parce qu'en fait regarder un
truc tu sais pas jouer pendant 8h
5 minutes 10 minutes 10 minutes ou à peu
près voilà mais même en rapide en fait
il y a beaucoup de gens qui jouent à
peine qui viennent
parce que ça se passe vite ce qui se
passe tu as pas de grande pause de 20
minutes entre deux coups
même mon père qui doit être en train de
regarder maintenant mais ce qui nous
disait alors qu'il était 2000 quand même
il a battu 2100
en fait ok enfin attendre 20 minutes
pour que le mec pousse son pion d'une
case et l'autre réfléchit c'est
compliqué et ok 2000 et l'eau je pense
qu'il est plus fort que 99% du chat il y
a des chances en tout cas quand il y a
du monde là peut-être qu'il y a un peu
moins de monde mais oui clique fort
mais même lui en fait
regarde pour regarder mais
c'est trop long et j'en ai absolument
rien à [ __ ]
oui j'aime beaucoup le format parti
complète en une heure bah ouais 1h le
truc c'est que ça laisse aux gens qui
qui qui
pas trop de temps dans la vie de fin qui
peuvent pas immobiliser une journée
entière journée de regarder en fait et
même si c'est un match aller-retour
c'est deux fois une heure tu diras ben
j'ai pas le temps j'ai un peu pour la
deuxième ou un pour la fin de la
première et de la deuxième et même deux
heures en fait tu peux encore le prendre
mais objectivement prendre 7 heures dans
tes journées tous les jours ça dure
c'est impossible en fait personne peut
le faire et heureusement d'ailleurs
ok le prix
de même
je pense sur combien de vélo fit si tu
rejoins au TV alors j'ai rejoué 10
parties à 3 ans et j'ai fait une perte à
23 50 je sais pas ce que ça vaut mais
c'est factual au moins j'ai perdu ma
première partie très bêtement j'étais
complètement gagnant contre un 24 50
espagnol
bon j'ai paniqué j'avais pas joué depuis
10 ans et après je voulais prendre une
mais je suis obligé de gagner pour
l'équipe
mais du coup si j'aurais fait perf à
23,40 sur 10 parties
je pense que ça va être à peu près mon
niveau mais bon
j'ai pas dit parti c'est déjà assez pour
se donner une idée généralement même si
c'est pas énorme
je suis très loin du niveau grand maître
en longue mais alors très très loin
inimaginablement loin
je clique un peu quoi
à un niveau ridicule
on sait pas
pourtant
ouais mais c'est un autre c'est un peu
la même chose je suis vraiment
spécialisé en [ __ ] en fait j'ai fait 10
parties longues en 15 ans et j'ai fait
peut-être 15000 bits sur tchaikom donc
aussi une question de pratique je suis
hyper entraînée pour bien jouer en 8 en
fait
donc forcément que je clique beaucoup
plus fort en blitz
mon ouvert mes ouvertures ma manière de
jouer tout est fait pour bien jouer en
Bliss ce calcul mâle les variantes
longues mais je suis très bien pour
aller petites tactiques à la con je suis
bien pour faire les finales et je
connais bien mes schémas donc en fait
l'archétype du joueur de Blitz
bien en finale arnaque des petites
ouvertures à la con mais tu connais bien
donc
même si on traite il y a pas de souci
mais si tu joues aux cartes Maintenant
plus
je suis remis à 4 plus en puissance
donc ça va
mais après si je m'entraînais à fond
pour rejoindre j'aurais différemment ma
d'ailleurs ça s'est vu quand il Caro il
a il s'entraînait pour les candidats il
a moins gagné title d'ailleurs
ce que tu modifies un peu
ce que je sais faire répartir à
l'aveugle avant oui mais maintenant ça
longtemps que je n'ai pas fait des
joueurs faibles j'y arriverai évidemment
mais j'aurais plus de mal qu'avant
il est pas parti pour reprendre KFC donc
il laisse le socle ce qui est dangereux
quoi
je sais pas ça fait vraiment dégénérer
pour Doodle c'est parti très vite en
plus
je pense aussi
il y a 6 minutes enfin quatre coups ça
va mais comme c'est si compliqué c'est
pas si simple
tout à fait acheter
plus doucement
tu revérifier tu as moins confiance
aussi
tu es doublement plus lent quoi
il a pas l'air serein ouais
Pascal qui est d'accord avec toi
je pense c'est tellement une évidence
il est pas où il y a
très loin et précis ou un mec fort en
tactique c'est à peu près la même chose
en général
à partir d'un certain niveau non mais
après ça peut être calcul très loin et
très précis ces gens stéréotype
ou n'est pas d'ailleurs qui vient de
gagner les candidats oui Caro j'ai un
Maxime il spote à vitesse de l'éclair
les schémas les trucs
c'est peut-être même le plus fort tout
je sais pas mais enfin ils sont tous
très forts quoi donc du radar qui est
vraiment au-dessus ou quoi mais c'est
voilà en tactique c'est voilà et kerwana
c'est moins la tactique peau de banane
instante mais il va calculer loin loin
bien
il est pas ouf pour être suivi en direct
mais bien pour lire le résultat à la fin
dans un journal bah c'est un peu ça mais
c'est un peu ce qu'on fait nous
généralement on regarde les parties
après
c'est pas fait pour être regardé en
direct en fait c'est pour
pour être lu
mais oui c'est un jeu très tactique
ça me fait penser un truc que disait
Vlad mais qui est très juste c'est comme
les joueurs sont devenus si forts qu'on
connaît aussi bien les ouvertures qu'on
est si bien préparé maintenant que du
coup réduire les cadences c'était
intéressant parce que le truc
intéressant c'était plus de savoir si tu
étais capable de calculer si tu avais la
bonne prépa et de finir mais c'est si tu
es capable de le faire quand tu as peu
de temps c'est ça l'exploit en fait de
faire un peu de temps c'est un peu comme
au tennis genre
en fait où tu veux en fait on sait tous
le faire mais quand tu vas le faire sous
une pression plus grande en fait
tout le monde mais beaucoup beaucoup des
joueurs pour être enchaîner les paniers
à trois points
mais comment tu vas les enchaîner
quand tu as quelqu'un en face de toi qui
va revenir dans un dixième de seconde en
fait tu es pas dans la bonne position
comment tu vas réussir à le faire
aujourd'hui même pas la séquence je sais
pas qui a raison ou quoi mais qui prend
des trois
D8
faut prendre
ok bon
OK et puis peut-être E4 ici serait le
meilleur mais ok et non en fait faire
là c'est sûr ça va
la position était comme ça il y a un
coup quoi il y a deux coups du coup il
fait ça il donne ce coup il fait ça il
redonne un coup au blanc donc là c'est
évident que ça va pas
et en plus il a joué tempo
alors je sais pas quand parce qu'on
approche du 40e il y a peut-être pas une
en deux coups mais
là ça prend forme si la somption passait
hyper bien placé il va faire [ __ ] à 5
il va essayer de coulisser sur la
colonne C
c'est pas une belle partie à quel point
c'est gagnant juste mieux mais
vu de la dynamique ça a l'air de c'est
pas une partie bien joué mais bon ça se
comprend
mon exemple armé le tir au pistolet à 25
mètres sur cible en temps limité
beaucoup plus de différence entre les
très bons tireurs et les tireurs normaux
entre quelques secondes et plusieurs
dizaines de secondes mais ouais c'est
exactement ça acheter quatre talents
c'est le même exemple c'est vrai un
moment donné quand tu es dans
l'excellence on veut savoir tu es super
excellent mais en fait c'est comment
sous la limite du temps tu vas réussir à
faire ton excellence mais c'était un des
arguments un des arguments principaux de
vlades en fait c'est logique
tous les domaines de la vie en fait
quand atteint l'excellence au bout d'un
moment surtout que le sport la question
c'est comment tu vas réussir être aussi
parfait avec aussi peu de temps et ça
c'est kiffant
mais ça avant qu'on comprenne dans les
échecs je reviens dans 20 ans ils ont
toujours pas compris ça ils continueront
à te parler dans les élections de Mintel
et beaucoup plus transparent que l'autre
même Top Chef c'est limité en temps bah
ouais mais en fait c'est normal bah oui
ça recommence
et du coup tu vas te démerder tu vas
peut-être pas faire exactement ce que tu
voulais tu auras moins de temps pour
cette cuisson est-ce que tu le fais
quand même ou tu te démerdes mais parce
que dans la vie tu es toujours limité en
temps pour tout on va dire quand tu es
chef de dans un resto le mec arrive à
table il attend 4 heures enfin oui mais
mon truc est vraiment excellent oui j'ai
plus faim
la différence serait bon et le mauvais
joueur d'échec bon joueur
il clique au hasard mais mais bien quoi
même Ken est une histoire de temps hey
tout est une histoire de temps fou à
Luna
Neder même au foot plus tu montes le
niveau plus les défenseurs sont bons par
rapport aux attaquants et moins de temps
et dans les intervalles les passes les
trucs non
tu gardes bien du temps c'est stupide en
fait mais bon
c'est dans tout comme ça mais bon aux
échecs on veut pas le comprendre ou je
sais pas
ok
de bosser la stratégie avant la tactique
je sais plus je vois plus la question
mais j'ai eu à peu près non il y a rien
d'idiot mais bon faut quand même que
soit au point sinon la stratégie tu vas
te prendre des pots de bananes à chaque
fois tu pourras pas la mettre en place
en fait
je sais pas quoi
c'est plus dans l'air du
jamais vraiment été dans l'air du temps
à vrai dire parce que déjà dans les
années 50 les gens voulaient réformer le
truc
déjà il y a 70 ans c'était plus trop
dans l'air du temps et
il y a 150 ans à vrai dire c'était pas
dans l'air du temps non plus donc
c'était dans l'air du temps enfin il y a
200 ans on va dire
c'était pas dans le temps c'était dans
l'air du temps pendant une toute petite
période
par contre je pense qu'avant qu'on
apprenne des ordis se former était
sûrement mieux c'était discutable en
fait cette période là
les arguments pour les cadences longues
étaient horribles
moi je comprenais et c'est il y avait un
intérêt
bah comme la journée
il disait que ceux qui distinguaient les
top joueurs des joueurs très forts c'est
que les top joueurs enchaînent tout un
tas de bonnes décisions que les joueurs
très forts sont aussi capables de
prendre mais à chaque fois un peu plus
vite par exemple le top joueur français
ici en 0,5 secondes plus vite et après
30 décisions ils se retrouvent assez
loin devant pour prendre un fight qui
décide la partie ou quelque chose comme
ça bah ouais mais c'est
en fait c'est souvent ça en fait qui
détermine après
non non mais c'est pas faux du tout tout
ça
mais oui c'est à peu près la même chose
vous échecs en réalité
de la journée elle est simple que des
nuls et une époque à gagner le tournoi
là on attend bon ça va quoi on attend le
résultat de cette partie ouais
alors 3 minutes
mais pas plaisant enfin
très étrange
incompréhensible
il a pas vu fou des 6 quoi mais c'était
pas loin c'était deux coups
de P4 tu es tellement bien
[Musique]
c'est tout ce que tu rêves quoi
demain on peut avoir un sympa en cas de
victoire de
c'est vrai que du coup dings sera obligé
de gagner quoi et toi tu es mon cas nul
d'ailleurs a priori parce que nacre a
peut-être le meilleur des partages ah
oui parce que du coup c'est une autre
débilité
pour être pour seulement
de berger qui compte
va comprendre
toujours écrit à l'emporte-pièce c'est
règlement il réfléchissent pas
en fait on s'en fout il finit deuxième
mais on s'en fout pas et donc c'est d'où
l'idée de clarifier avant le tournoi
Carlson avec du bon tu joues tu joues
pas tu nous dis si tu réponds pas on va
consacrer que tu joues pas bam ouais
c'est ça donc tu te démerdes c'était on
n'a pas de réponse
ultimatum à telle heure minuit donc du
coup bah là tu aurais mis deuxième place
il y a des partages ou pas
est-ce que ce jeu serait beaucoup moins
apprécié une heure si les joueurs
avaient 25 + 10 110 généralement qui
perdraient 100 points et l'eau de niveau
de jeu
ce qu'on dit après je sais pas si c'est
vrai tu vois moi ça jouera déjà très
bien en fait
mais moi je pense c'est même moins
maintenant parce que je pense c'est plus
pour le 15 c'est plus dix probablement
pour le 25 juillet 75 points donc
27 ça jouera entre allez on va dire
entre 2007 et
2770 au lieu de jouer entre 27 60 et 28
30 20 28 60 quoi
mais ça j'aurais quand même très bien
quoi ça j'aurais très bien et le truc
c'est que là on est pas à l'abri d'une
mauvaise partie comme ça là par exemple
ou ce que firuja nous a fait quelquefois
dans le tournoi ou un truc comme ça donc
en fait on aurait l'assurance de partie
d'excellents niveau à chaque fois ça
pourrait se discuter mais en fait on a
même pas station là ça peut ne pas bien
jouer et rester très loin
si la partie de ma carte est-ce que tu
ferais je tournoi à 20h en stream c'est
pas sûr franchement c'est pas sûr je
sens vraiment épuisé personnellement pas
Fab mais ça fait encore qu'on fasse le
recap
on verra on verra pas sûr
ça a fini à 19h pas sur si ça finit vers
20h par contre
sûr que non sûr que non ouais mais
dans le quart d'heure on y arrive
en tout cas on a entre guillemets fait
notre
devoirs on a quand même beaucoup parlé
en live
on en a beaucoup parlé en live
avec une heure de plus que ça changeait
quelque chose n'en rajouter du temps ça
changerait rien honnêtement réduire le
rajout d'une heure le Pass à une
demi-heure et rajouter les 30 secondes à
partir du 40e à mon avis ça changerait
quasiment rien oh non déjà ce serait un
premier pas il faudra le faire déjà ça
c'est sûr
c'est ça en fait tu rajoutes pas une
heure chacun une demi-heure chacun et de
remettre en seconde direct déjà on
économise serait une heure plus le truc
une heure trente déjà
c'est pas mal déjà
non mais 30 secondes dès le début
d'ailleurs
40 30 secondes et 30 minutes
ça serait déjà une avancée
mais ça réduirait pas la qualité des
parties ça
meilleure partie dans ce tournoi interne
du jeu sur mon rapport Ding non
rapporte la meilleure sûrement et après
il y a pas loin peut-être execo ou en
tout cas qui a marqué aussi c'est Ikaru
contre contre
il a vraiment été juste propre en fait
propre mais en fait quand il a pu gagner
il a bien gagné il a jamais fait de
faute aussi il a pas s'il en a fait une
mais
contre quand j'ai gagné Ding il a bien
gagné les deux fois qu'il avait dû faire
déjà la partie Jack gagne avec les
Blancs elle est bien
mais pas la partie allez
il a fait du jeu quoi
pas faux
ce que nepo avait dit au dernier
candidat il l'a remis en application ici
et c'est ça ça se traduit les candidat
c'est-à-dire le mec qui viennent en
général c'est celui qui perd pas
tu vas perdre une quoi
Maxime
mais bon la dernière servait à rien en
fait il était déjà gagné donc on peut
pas vraiment la compter
mais donc voilà tu peux en perdre une
mais il faut pas faut pas prendre l'eau
quoi
en fait s'il peut se dire ça pour le
Championnat du Monde aussi
il n'a jamais été en direct n'est poètes
je crois qu'il a pas été en direct
au hasard un peu hein
de pas se mettre en PLS c'est clique
mais ouais faut que je lui montre qu'il
refasse sa prépa et qui clique et qui
clique ça ferait pas aller quand même
bien bien il a pas montré non plus 10000
choses mais la pétrole on a vu qu'il
pouvait avoir une faille ici ou là qu'on
a la classe c'était pas c'était
dangereux il était mal contre famille ça
fait une cahier H4 donc il peut encore
exter des idées on fera bien qu'il la
blinde ou qui viennent avec une autre
idée mais je pense qu'il va revenir avec
et qui répare complètement la
Catalane
mais s'il peut sécher la Catalane ça
serait une énorme avancée pour lui
est-ce que tu sais choquer tu sais je
Descartes bon voilà tu es pas mal quoi
2600 puzzle et ce qui doit continuer
jusqu'à 3000 ou faire des parties
rapides je dirais de jouer hein enfin
les puzzles c'est bien pour te préciser
l'oeil mais le but des échecs c'est de
jouer quand même
c'est des parties est-ce qu'on ferait
pas une petite pause c'est ce que serait
pas la pause allez attends ah bah oui
bah en plus on est reparti sur beaucoup
de temps non on est reparti
de comprendre cette petite position et
à tout à l'heure à tout de suite
c'est pas passé grand chose juste sur
juste F3 et c'est à l'air complètement
terminé bon et Douda ça se voit il sait
que c'est foutu
ouais bon bah il va juste falloir
attendre en fait
on fait une pause alors
non mais en vrai j'ai envie de te dire
oui
bah il se passe rien il y a les deux
chaises foncé je sais plus quoi vous
dire Fab ne sait plus quoi vous dire en
fait on a tout dit le ton est terminé il
y a plus dangereux pour rien
et la partie est gagnée donc bon il faut
finir c'est tout ah mais c'est un coca
là ah mais en fait c'est la même société
quoi
en fait on a compris quoi
mais bon il a pas l'air très sprite non
et perso je préfère le coca
j'aime pas trop je trouve vraiment que
c'est un goût chimique hyper chimique
c'est pas le problème mais c'est du coca
c'est un truc si je viens juste d'orange
je prends un jus d'orange un vrai quoi
ça c'est installé dans ton
imaginaire comme un coca quoi comme un
coca ouais
j'ai pas goûté depuis longtemps le
sprite ici une sorte de limonade que le
Spring c'était pas mal hein Orangina
j'en ai eu un il y a pas longtemps ça
faisait des années que j'avais pas vu
d'orange
tu peux te faire un petit indien ou quoi
enfin c'est cool faut bien quand même
secouer avant pas trop non plus pas
mais
il y a un truc que j'ai pas vu depuis
très longtemps c'est le Cacolac ça j'ai
jamais
goûté
du cacao froid quoi mais bon enfin c'est
sympa quoi c'est Jean-Pierre Papin
le Ginny ouais j'adore aussi bah si ton
truc s'agrum c'est quand même
le cacac c'est pas frais c'est pas ouf
bah ouais mais ça se voit après
vu les chocolaté dans une bière dans une
bouteille de bière
comme coca oui parce que le coca en fait
je vais parler de ah mais en gros on
prend ça comme un comme le goût naturel
mais il t'a jamais bouffé un coca tu as
pu bouffer des kakis mais c'est pas
pareil et donc bah le coca semble
naturel quoi alors pas trop quoi
donc en devant un coca je bois le truc
pur très bien
alors que le Fanta tu sens que il se
passe des choses
et être inutile ouais tu es mieux mais
il a mal joué et là maintenant il est
foutu était mal je suis mieux puis
foutu puis égal puis foutu partie de
merde en gros
c'est l'heure de la pause
je récupère de la batterie
s'est blessé quoi
sinon c'est accroché en 3e set il y a eu
60064 de premier donc ciné mène de 7-0
mais là OK
britannique et on attend ça serait pas
tarder à Djoko contre
le fou quoi le gars est inconnu mais il
vient de gagner trois sur heure on va
tomber de neuf en finale et là il
défonce
mais c'est intéressant chez les filles
mariés Garcia
quand même dans quelques années ouais
très vite fait quand même
un truc il y a un truc
mais ce qui lui ressemble complètement
Fabien tu sais
il a fait quoi sur hashra il a fait F3
et comme prévu
[Musique]
au Grand Prix c'est Carl sense qui a
gagné avec les Ferrari
je sais pas la suite du truc classement
on était bloqué à regarder les candidats
qui étaient aujourd'hui plus intéressant
que jamais
ça va être chaud là pour le gamin les
300000 en fait c'est impossible non
inscriptions du tournoi qui vont un peu
rentrer dedans je sais pas combien de
joueurs mais à 30 euros même si ça fait
mais bon dur de toute façon
à cette avec sa tour pour s'accrocher
mais bon
ce que tu dessines c'est un coup je sors
ces 6 en fait déjà
tu m'as déjà peut-être qu'il prend le 5
de suspense
mais la dernière ronde de main ça va
être loin
mais Douda tu vois là je crois pas que
des conditions de trop
trop cherché à faire des choses ça peut
finir vite avec une épaule
qu'est-ce qu'on a dans mon programme
catalan et sinaka est bien préparé ça
peut faire un peu comme nepora Java quoi
on sait pas tu vois c'est peut-être une
option et donc on a ça car on a fini
quoi
et rapport à jabov on sait pas
on a regardé la petite interview ça se
donnait pas et ça se voit que il
considère pas du tout que Magnus joue
pas oui personne considère qui jouera
pas en fait c'est
tout le monde quoi
il y a le côté business aussi la son
truc qui j'ai l'impression après j'en
sais rien mais à pas l'air de marcher du
feu de dieu
et s'il perd le titre de champion du
monde enfin c'est
malheureusement il a aussi ce truc là
qui fait qui pas obligé mais bon
[Musique]
il y a aussi ce facteur là qui me fait
dire qu'il jouera quoi ça rajoute encore
un facteur on va dire
alors aujourd'hui oui on se retrouvera
demain pour la dernière ronde mais
aujourd'hui c'est la dernière les trois
autres ont fini par la nul
ça se voit même sa posture et tout que
c'est pas du tout la même position que
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
et partir rapide au championnat du monde
d'accord
de déclaration dans ce sens là mais ça
paraît très logique
mais c'est déjà à moitié le cas
des partages sont rapides et que ça va
souvent des partages mais oui c'est pour
avoir une importance plus grande si tu
en mets plus que c'est pas juste un
simple départage il y a des sept que je
sais pas en fait
tu fais ça tu voulais la boîte de Panda
comme les gens vont adorer les rapides
et détester les longues tout la boîte à
Pandore et où il y aura plus de de
longues
est-ce qu'on sera vraiment bien sûr
d'avoir le meilleur joueur Fabien
prise puis on prend des systèmes pour
défendre le pion tu as bouffé
les pions
déjà abandonné
quand même pour être bien sûr
tu peux nous repasser la partie
juste la petite sicilienne donc la nage
d'orf avec le Cali qui revient F3 les
ventes tranquille
voilà donc après
je connaissais pas pourquoi pas H6 ou C4
x 6 classique fullet 3 qui est ici
chez vaste soupçonnant ça donne les
accès à la caisse
et puis là on s'est dit ok très bien en
gros hein
et puis
[Musique]
puis en fait ce qui est sécable à son G5
dans un grand tour en B6 ils vend des 7
propose l'échange en fuite n'a qu'à pas
il repart à 7 puis il va taper la dame
sur sa route et va bouffer au 4 donc là
même mieux je dirais c'est la même chose
champion
bon ça manœuvre
et puis là il est très bien il fait pas
B4 il rentre dans les complications qui
lui sont pas spécialement hyper
favorables c'est-à-dire que là c'est pas
clair puis va partir sur du KFC il est
option des envies au lieu de le prendre
et il fait un aller-retour là c'est
vraiment une phase plusieurs fois je
pense
partie de merde en fait en vrai c'est
vrai
il y a pas de lien quoi
c'est ce battle quoi ouais mais ça
arrive manque de temps peut-être Fab
il y a des gens qui aiment l'esprit
c'est l'exode qui aime le marathon
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas avoir les deux
bah ouais nous c'est ce qu'on voudrait
en fait avoir les marathons et les
sprints tout le temps
aussi quoi
de faire les temps qui veulent c'est
loin de là c'est pas une idée de tirant
d'ailleurs vous aurez plus jamais en
lente moi j'aime bien et bah très bien
c'est de proposer les deux en fait
ce que je dis toujours à Jean-Marie mais
bon après tu as les gens qui me donnent
l'argument ouais mais si du coup s'il y
a des rapides et des lentes les gens
vont plus regarder que les rapides
ça je l'ai déjà lu pas mal de fois
en résumé demain on fait n'est pas
bah en fait c'est quand même l'actu la
peau partie de mes pots
à cette partie là elle est trop décousue
et
Fabi j'ai l'impression que c'est juste
une prépa quoi oui oui c'est sûr
en force
qui regarde les marathons pendant 4-5
heures en entier il y a des gens qui
doivent aimer pourquoi pas mais tant
mieux enfin moi j'ai pas fait mais
pourquoi pas tu as le marathon et tout
je crois que le marathon des JO tu dois
regarder un petit peu quoi
c'est plus court qu'une partie d'échec
mais les étapes du Tour de France est
différent parce que tu regardes les
images tour de la France
[Musique]
mais même le tout enfin c'est pas tout
le monde dira toutes les étapes des fois
tu te connectes tu te mets la télé à 16h
tu dis tiens ils vont pas tarder tu
regardes moi je regarde pas les étapes
de plat regarde en entier il faut avoir
envie mais après c'est beau quand même
des fois des fois tu regardes un peu
[Musique]
pour la sieste
mais c'est comme là en fait si on avait
plein de capsules de reportage tout le
temps on te montre tient en Espagne à ça
on va voir un musée on va voir un truc
machin ça pourrait être sympa
au départ de la ronde alors que tu
penses de ça
après ce serait long quand même pour les
échecs
avec les capsules ça changerait tout
mais on a un budget complètement
différent
beaucoup de gens qui regardent et comme
personne regarde et que tout le monde
s'en fout et tu peux pas faire c'est
en fait c'est un peu le truc c'est un
peu comme c'est une société que tu as un
truc qui marche pas du tout et tu
continues à mettre masse de fric dedans
pour bien te couler ben normalement bon
bah non enfin tout le monde s'en fout tu
prends
la direction quoi mais non mais je sais
quand j'étais avec Eurosport là c'était
pas du dire du tout mais c'était un des
beaucoup plus vivant le résumé ah bah
oui que tu as des petites interviews au
milieu tu fais un classement tu fais une
petite animation en truc enfin tu as
besoin de ça ça peut pas être que des
images de joueurs qui jouent aux échecs
et qui réfléchissent mais bon ça demande
de toi qui a bossé pour un Eurosport le
budget pour ça sont énormes et
évidemment il y a quand même évidemment
il y avait un monteur
il y avait un graphiste il y avait
la personne qui filme le tournoi
et il y avait moi il y avait quelqu'un
au-dessus de nous pour chat Potter
une équipe quoi et tu vas faire 10000
vues
direct c'était juste un reportage enfin
c'est des vidéos sponsorisées je crois
ouais
sport en fait ils disent oui on passe
sur en fait il payait pour que le sport
les passe là je crois que c'était le
même système
donc c'est les organisateurs des tours
qui payent pour être sur les chaînes
télé ça c'est extraordinaire
mais c'est beau
en fait la Ligue 1
montre-moi s'il te plaît
avec santé Fabien
c'est déjà le cas
mais oui donc c'est pour dire que ouais
si on voulait faire un truc comme ça il
faudrait une équipe de ouf
c'est un peu ce que faites comme en
anglais mais
de mon sac il y a pas énormément de vues
mais cela dit ça fait pas une influence
ouais après pour l'image machin et puis
c'est un peu leur rôle dans les échecs
aussi ils sont un peu la marque leader
du jeu et la première fois elles sont
peut-être vraiment le partenaire
officiel aussi des candidats donc ils
veulent marquer le coup aussi de faire
un truc bien
dans leur carrière des charges aussi sur
le plateau il craint
ça reste quand même très loin de
[Musique]
d'une production du Tour de France c'est
ou même dans match de Ligue 1 en fait
avec des plans fixes
aussi quoi
de toute façon la Bonne Nouvelle comme
je faisais c'est comment ça change plus
grand chose dans le sens où les gens qui
qui ont découvert les échecs qui ont été
d'écouter des compétitions et du coup
continue à faire mal ou pas ça change
quasiment plus rien maintenant ça
changera le jour où tu auras un prochain
buzz il faudrait être prêt avoir un bon
produit mais tant que tu as pas de
prochaines buzz ça change pas
[Musique]
plus sur les échecs et de continuer à
regarder les tournois moi je trouve ça
marrant à regarder
enfin c'est surtout à jouer que c'est
marrant les échecs en fait pas vrai dire
il va faire pousser trois
bon on t'invite à regarder les futurs
tournois si on est comment en tout cas
mais
grandir ça pourrait être mieux fait dans
le format quoi voilà
allez sa bataille c'est vrai que c'est
beau
ce battage je crois que c'est là qu'on
s'amuse le plus quand même à regarder il
y a toujours des dingues
et donc c'est plus de choses au niveau
amateurs qui sont plus sympa regardez
même les bits spontaner ce qu'on fait
qu'on organise c'est sympa à regarder
c'est cool quand même mon père a plus
qu'il fait le Thunder ce que les
candidats quoi
donc non non il y a d'autres contenus
qui sont plus cool que c'est tournant là
et ça fait plus de vues sur la chaîne
redif que les rediffs des armes de ML au
nord-oui complètement des gens préfèrent
regarder à une rediff une partie de ce
battle marrante que d'une partie de mvl
ce qui veut quand même dire beaucoup
après viscontana c'est avec les joueurs
des candidats ça serait énorme aussi
c'est juste les parties de 148 heures
qui sont relou à suivre mais les joueurs
des candidats sont trop chers
en 1960 c'est c'est vraiment beaucoup
combien c'était le X 2 tous les 10 ans
donc ça fait 3 6
12 24 48
96 dollars 180 000 peut-être 160
ça me paraît beaucoup mais moi j'ai dit
50000 tout à l'heure visuellement
j'aurais pensé 50000 c'est peut-être
plus
bon
un article qui me dit que 100 dollars il
y a un siècle ne veulent plus que 3,5
aujourd'hui ça doit être l'inverse
[Musique]
je sais pas je trouve pas d'article
comme ça sous la main qui peut peut-être
nous dire en dollars real 1960 combien
ça fait aujourd'hui un dollar
ok
c'est bon
bravo je sais pas vous avez trouvé les
infos
ok ok
etc et s'ils échangent la tour on va
aller en C7 ah basiquement c'est foutu
quoi
ça m'amuse comme variante
et ça illustre bien tous les problèmes
c'est que non seulement tu as le
problème du pion mais tu as aussi le
problème du match
c'est pas bien quoi
[Musique]
de faire
6 attaque la tour attaquage 5 bah quand
même là tu souffles le plus avec toi je
sais pas quoi je sais même pas
d'ailleurs mais bon ok enfin tu sens que
tu sens que tu es beaucoup plus de
réussite
après dur 13ième ronde la fatigue le
manque d'enjeu le machin il y a beaucoup
de choses qui se passent
cette deuxième place va se jouer aussi
sur des cadeaux
non mais là c'est un enchaînement de
mauvaise décision ne pas faire B4 pas
faire de prendre
je sais pas
mais c'est terminé
le vainqueur est connu mais bon ça joue
quand même
c'est un match de Coupe Davis il y a 3-0
mais qu'il y a le match 4 et le match 5
qui seront quand même diffusés aux
échecs à la différence du tennis
bon là c'est terminé en fait c'est un
peu étrange
[Musique]
pour nous aussi
le comprendre mais après
la deuxième ça sera bonne chance pour
les carreaux ou dingue
parce que Caro devra avoir 7,5
je suis vraiment sûr que Magnus jour a
le match si tu veux pas le laisser
complètement
il est complètement écœuré dedans
on voit la position mais juste si on
regarde juste comment il est sur les
points c'est deux personnes avec des
égaux absolument surdimensionnés et du
coup
il fera super le malin d'être champion
du monde Magnus fait super le malin tout
le temps et quand tu as deux personnes
qui font le malin qui se
tu as pas envie
en fait même si il perd il est sûr qu'il
va pas changer du monde
[Musique]
là il fait c'est son meilleur
jeu d'acteurs
je pense qu'il y a préfère le match non
mais il va
le match il va le gagner mais je veux
dire par là que
5 fois 4 donc il lui enlève et
je remets un petit lien pour pour le
fils de Bella qui a atteint une maladie
si vous voulez aider
il y a le lien dans le chat
save child of Chester yellow
S
pourquoi il s'en fiche ça
fait une heure qu'il aurait pu
abandonner déjà quasiment
on a eu le temps de faire une partie
complète
en rapide
quel joueur actuel selon vous profite le
plus de l'art des ordinateurs
probablement parce que c'est le meilleur
demain je pense qu'il Caro va faire
nulle facile mais bon
bonne chance je crois Ding il a plus le
mojo là
on peut pas trop lire
[Musique]
finale machin bon tranquille quoi
on sait pas trop dingue en fait
c'est
pas une position tu as qu'un coup pour
gagner donc tu as même pas envie de
sacrifier rien quoi en fait tu veux
prendre 5 tu veux pousser ton pion tu
fais une dame là
je pense qu'il repense plus à la partie
que à la position qu'il a actuellement
devant l'échiquier qu'est-ce que j'ai
foutu ouais comment j'ai pu perdre ça ou
quoi ce qui était vraiment avec son pion
de plus il était tellement bien
mais bon tu arrives plus la combien de
points ah peut-être ça peut jouer la
dernière place ce qui va rester ouais
en fait là rajouter du coup si on veut
des enjeux mais bon ces derniers
candidat tu peux pas jouer l'édition
suivante
ah ce serait beau ça du coup il y aura
toujours un enjeu pour la dernière place
je prends la première vous fait même
deux descentes je sais pas enfin tu
trouves un truc si tu veux garder ton
ton relayer quoi
tu as été trop nul la dernière fois
retourne avec la plèbe quoi
il fait ses petites grimaces
il est bien quoi mondial
joueur amateur
il reviendra dans 4 ans c'est pas la fin
du monde
ce format là on en a quoi
c'est sûr que je suis plus à la position
c'est sûr qu'il est dégoûté
sur la partie
il est temps d'aller dîner
quelque chose non il sait que c'est
foutu c'est ouais mais des fois tu
abandonnes pas parce que tu
[Musique]
es tellement dégoûté une partie de merde
où est-ce que j'ai raté c'est pas
possible d'avoir perdu et
cherche une arnaque non même pas là
je pense c'est juste par dégoût ça
arrive
je vais
donne un pion
pourquoi ce pion est trop fort en fait
ça
[Musique]
ça va faire trop
genre se lève souvent après avoir joué
c'est pour se détendre
cet empêche pas de réfléchir quand même
à la partie même en te baladant
tu as remarqué quand on roule en voiture
sur l'autoroute on a de moins en moins
de d'insectes écrasé sur les pare-chocs
et sur les vitres
c'est peut-être possible j'arrive pas à
comprendre pourquoi avant il y avait
beaucoup plus d'insectes tu roulais
l'été
de pollution qui meurent je sais pas là
pour le coup plus je sais pas pourquoi
également des insectes peut-être je sais
pas des pesticides des trucs
quelqu'un dit 60% des insectes
moi je sais pas
parce que c'est bien ou c'est mal
je crois que c'est important je crois
aussi c'est de la bouffe pour les
oiseaux non
les moustiques j'aime pas trop mais
mais il y en avait beaucoup plus avant
c'est sûr
je me doute que ça peut être terrible
mais j'en sais rien donc c'est pour ça
que je demande
quand on sait pas il vaut mieux demander
quelqu'un dit vous êtes idiot ou quoi
ben quand tu sais pas tu demandes en
fait être idiot c'est parler sans savoir
c'est pas demandé quand on sait pas
c'est
complexe mais bon gérant cette sensation
quand tu prends la voiture il y en a
plus sur le pare-choc sur le pare-brise
par contre j'ai plus souvent des
moucherons à la maison
dès que je laisse des fruits et tout
comme ça
qui viennent sur les fruits que tu as
lavés ou j'en sais rien moi
c'est peut-être con ce que je dis
à cause des frais quand tu as les fruits
viennent quoi j'ai l'impression qu'ils
viennent plus qu'avant
ou pas
dans un truc joli là il fait [ __ ] des
quatre
c'est joli en fait
ça il y aura pas
de l'ordi tout à l'heure il disait
mais bon
ça il peut y avoir quand même parce que
c'est quand même
mais est-ce qu'on peut pas faire moi je
vais aller faire
et les abeilles il y a pas des gens qui
font des trucs pour les abeilles
tellement important les abeilles c'est
pas important
pendant le confinement je voyais
beaucoup plus d'abeilles d'ailleurs tous
les animaux les dauphins intervenus et
tout c'était très bien quoi
je me demande des fois il serait pas
faire des semis qui confinement par an
et pour les insectes pour la nature
mais c'est vrai que c'était fou il y
avait tellement de choses qui a
a non mais sur mon balcon en premier
confinement c'était fou la veille comme
j'ai des petits citronniers
bon d'habitude elles viennent pas du
tout quasiment pas et là je sais pas il
y en avait plein il a fait torse 8
direct
ensuite
il fait architecte on demande de plus en
plus de [ __ ] des espèces de ruche sur
les toitures des terrasses idées
la nature qui
reprend un petit peu ses droits
ça clique
je sais pas ce serait si grave si on
était enfermé enfin enfermé semi enfermé
on va dire
de survécu mais genre les magasins les
machins les trucs comme ça
je pense plus peut-être économique
qu'autre chose sinon je pense qu'on
arrivera très bien nous
je sais pas comment ça marche pas
et donc Douda qui s'impose non
merci Fab de m'avoir repris et donc
demain il y aura le choc pour la
deuxième place digne d'un camera
l'emporter
[Musique]
il perd pas demain il sera selon
voilà ce sera l'enjeu de cette dernière
ronde et voir si une peau finit à vaincu
c'est pas vraiment l'enjeu parce qu'en
fait
si en fait il gagne il rattrapy carreau
mais s'il rattrapie carreau c'est une
Ding a battu et carreau donc il passe
devant donc il passe devant donc il y
aura qu'un seul qu'une seule partie à en
jeu relatif on va dire
il pourrait pas y avoir de débordage
pour la seconde place en plus
il y aura un second sale donc merci à
tous d'avoir suivi on se retrouve demain
pour pour la suite et fin de ce tournoi
des candidats qui auraient été palpitant
jusqu'à la 12e ronde voilà merci à tous
ciao ciao et n'oubliez pas le petit lien
pour pour le petit je le remets dans le
chat merci à tous Ciao